l'ue prend 2,9 du tata steel on se
retrouve après deux jours de pause de
repose tout fait donc aujourd'hui on a
une affiche en particulier entre les
deux hommes de tête ouais sinon on a un
mac un cube blanc promet d'ailleurs de
voir
cinq et demi sur huit souffre
son
aventure irie évident exactement
et
de rapports des
partis fédéraux du panel de tous points
forts et avant impôts
donc
[Musique]
c'est impossible très vite il a gagné
quand même juste avant jours de repos
rapport il est régulier donc
on verra on verra tout est possible ici
je crois
savoir
quand on accorde au parlement avec ça on
a doublé
il pas un peu là le verger le ils n'ont
pas besoin fort donc c'est vraiment à
marquer temps des loups qui vit à
paris
fils de pièces intéressant
et donc après avoir tapé jean
paul dubois 29 ans
de leur côté affiche donc toujours eu
l'idée d'appliquer donc reportée après
avoir informé en premier on va
surveiller l'ouverture de traits ici
pour voir si une petite maison qui tombe
sur terre
donc
les deux mois pour 90 ces valeurs sont
pas durs groupe de supposés
donc
apparemment on trouve allait pouvoir on
aura droit
votez
plus grands délires caruana quand
j'en ai le billet dans une rouge
et karma
donc une partie oui à gué septembre est
reparti au barça suivent ou pas mais
on va voir
ben il arriva à monter
on est à
30 des risques avec les noirs comme
quinzaine avaient pu faire contre le
camp des lieux ce après avoir si ça paye
vous n'avez toujours pas remporté la
moindre partie aussi d'avoir envie de
créer un petit peu une petite surprise
et d'appariement
prague lille prend à des filins les
bienvenus au pire
neutre dans l'expérience a
fallu néanmoins combos et géographie
du monde
[Musique]
et donc voir les demandeurs est
extrêmement solide tandis que le
conduire devant le meilleur joueur
est
mal vu et
je suis d'accord avec toi on sait jamais
ouais je ne vois pas du tout car
caroline
non mais peu le concert prévu ce brave
on a vu comme depuis les toits il fait
des erreurs il fait aussi des bonnes
choses mais quand il se trompe un peu et
car ils tiennent six arrivées en
profiter il reste capable de saisir les
opportunités qu'on lui a faim bah comme
contre
on trouve encore elle cessa exactement
exactement et bonjour dans le chat a
pour toile et arnaud au passage en
caisse ou comment vous entendez ce tout
moi je n'entende pas hyper rapide je
dois vous me donnez un que vous nous
donniez un petit retour le manque ou par
mail à peut-être peut-être ellaone bref
les petits tours déjà des présentations
pour la rando journée donc vraiment
monsieur principe annoncée sera alors
qu'un certain médias parce que les deux
hommes mais le tournoi et quinten cas
les pièces blanches qui risquent des
amendes plutôt bien contre l'azéri avec
les blancs elles émettent l'accession à
l'occasion de reprendre les rênes du
tournoi on se mettait à regina correct
wardwell microsoft semble loin mais pour
le coup
on le coule moi aussi l'entente pas très
bien donc c'est là je vais voir si ça
s'améliore
et on va perdre tour voici pour
présenter la partie challenger ou martin
d'hères morizet toujours à la recherche
de sa première victoire se trouve dans
ce tournoi
donc mais les contrevenants pourraient
donc au près
et
en fait
[Musique]
un joueur qui pourrait être vraiment un
génie
[Musique]
créatif les comités dans l'ouverture et
pour s'amuser au premier meilleur temps
et du coup
[Musique]
à avons réglé les blancs et puis je
voudrais voir kylie qui venait de
menacer
rouge à merde sur le ps est pour lui car
aux deux phases la pacific ou énorme il
à 25,39 bout il n'est pas beaucoup plus
que marc andriat et puis voilà comme tu
l'as dit là les blancs c'est quand même
un bon appareil mots pour décoller
nul doute comme en bas juste avant le
jour de repos qui peut lui redonner un
petit peu confiance en nous qu'on espère
qu'il va enfin
réussir à gagner sa première partie
d'entre moi qui les ferait beaucoup de
bien je pense que mon moral c'est
toujours de la 1/2 sur un ennemi pardon
sur
sur victor je crois ouais
ouais faut que ces anonymous
effectivement je vous entends pas très
bien sauf 1 depuis le début je
voulais pas me lancer donc je sais plus
fort ça vient de sa connexion parce que
les réglages chaussures au baseball
indiqué je l'entends comme vous
j'ai pas super c'est peut-être si tu
seras mieux en
monnayant et toutes celles ehpad on
verra
avec deux fois mais j'avais trouvé une
faille il a
enfin payé un pote qui va le payer avec
complex complet de paris dans quelques
minutes
alors on va se monter directement
qu'avec la partie toujours comme on à
dire au top de champion du monde et la
media europe évidemment peu de cours ont
été joués le week-end car celle qu'a
choisi des cats à 13 ans depuis le début
du tournoi l'a souvent joué qu'avec
trois premiers coups avec les blancs
et c'est peut-être à son adversaire plus
de choix et là il a commencé par des 4
et italia 6 et donc avait prêté joue au
second post ouf et on est parti sur
un candidat
et ici le petit j'ai trois là c'est du
archi-classique mam et a décidé
d'accepter ce candidat mon prono louche
on chez 4 car ce n est parti à l'appel
il y revient ou à voir ou à revoir ce
qui est choisi comme ouverture vous en
reste un petit peu puisque je pense que
les deux joueurs vont jouer assez vite
le début là dessus pour voir comment ça
évolue après on ira voir si on a des
parties intéressantes ailleurs
y est
alors
[Musique]
donc infliger de dégâts comme dans une
grande ligne on est dans une logique
clairement
peut s'attendre
à foot et deux chauffeurs
ont écoulé le cam aller vers le cloud ok
des duels déjouer la a5 est le principal
et a5 est reparti à tempo
mais oui
moi donc je l' ai déjà vu pareille de
fouad chehat coéquipiers que je savais
aussi par équipe avec la noire donc
par procuration je connais un peu
alors du coup l'idée de 0,5 c'est quoi
cette poussée glace sont sûrement je
vois reprendre avec le pion et ça se
fait alors c'est pas du tout à l'égout
principaux de ma jambe et 4 mais ça
amènerait quand même une structure de
place étonnante car leur adoption doublé
comme ça si tôt dans la partie
amélie 43 votants pêche aux casiers de
sortir effectivement
pour bien sûr dans ce genre de position
peut espérer récupérer au moins dix
depuis emmenée pour les blancs mais mais
ce qui est intéressant ici c'est que ça
ouvrirait la cob a pour les noirs ou
métis une pression sur le pion à deux et
c'est pour ça que c'est pas quelque
chose de très joués par les bleus a
priori c'est pas ça hyper prometteur
partiel nouvelles idées dix ans robert
donc sur à 5
parce qu'on peut rockets notamment ça
doit être
le plus standard et pleins de repos et
ensuite je m'appelle surpris ici doit
juste réfléchir
à quelles lignes leur vie d'aujourd'hui
quel type de position puisque baladeur
savoir hyper tactique quand même câble
beaucoup les complications donc
peut-être lorgnant sur un terrain plus
calme où il mettrait une petite pression
tranquillement dans son style ça peut
être une option choisie par l'ancienne
voie la
1re
partie comme pour réfléchir un petit peu
on va peut-être les à bordeaux d'un
instant et voir si il ya deux ouvertures
qui sont un petit peu avancé en gîte
chèques
alors la position tu as l'impression la
plus
belle plus inhabituel peut-être que la
plume aaron swartz agde foulant et
cariat qui nous pour aller faire un tour
puisque je vois déjà ya et plusieurs que
l'on vous laisse j'ai tracté un
spécialiste des moules frites chaudes
jour dans ce tournoi tu te rappelles
c'était contre qui il avait perdu contre
rapport à une partie là les dépendances
et comprennent forest il avait avec les
noirs des chiots à
l'inde qui ont doublé sur une sur une
cia ne s'était mal passé non
hélas ils écoutent et blanc dont il a
déjà on voit deux paires de tourner où
elle est en en plus ça tu vas sûrement
reperdant on va voir comment on arrivé
là mais j'ai choisi des cats
il a fait une espèce de système de long
dans une impression stouff qui devrait
la mode un peu plus haut niveau
maintenant
ouattara
moi je claque pas aux 20 déjà donc
le e mais non je ne peux m
comment mieux mais
parce que yao 4 md court je vais sur v
sous pas de double sortie c'est vraiment
moche est donc
peut-être un pc
acceptable je suis d'accord salut salut
telle idée merci pour le raid tordu à
toi
si jamais tu restes un petit peu mais tu
veux voir des courts j'imagine ouest ou
fin je te conseille de passer sur ton
téléphone sera sûrement mieux
hockey balle revient à la vie ok
on va perdre tout faire d'un ce temps
correct
c'est gentil ça swing sound mais c'est
pas outils mais quand même on va voir si
ça s'améliore
je reprends du coup avec les parties
travailleront ce petit système de l'eau
de derrière les fagots qui nous sort
contre contre cariatides lui normal de
revoir on va très bien à toi et du cou
du coup comment et le souffle nouveau et
ce qu'il est aussi bon que le beaujolais
ou pas
alors qu'elle minerait libérer les
malades kevin parent document est le
maître maintenant rien à voir avec avec
des collections sont pas au final ça a
l'air bien pour moi j'étais baisser un
peu je pense était légèrement fort on va
nous dire
[Musique]
quelques véhicules notamment
le système répondre est-ce que tu
connais bien ou pas avec les noirs
toujours comment doit est ce que c'est
ça que c'est justement quelque chose que
tu emploies
et pour dire
bonjour parce que ce qui s'est passé
après un style il a retardé la prise de
quelques coups et
actualisées et du coup on voit que
carradine c'est intéressant tout de
suite sont écrits à ce fameux fou on
sent dans un grand degré avant par
exemple que les blancs potentiellement
lui laisse une case de repli donc tu as
une idée de mon geste vous invite avec
les noirs
et on voit que des pions double est ce
qui pouvait sembler inhabituel
ne font pas forcément peur aux blancs
ici parce qu'il considère que si la
crise
vont être gâté non il n'est pas si moche
qui compteront l'aga de 5
je t'avoue que moi je préfère manquer
cette structure pour j'ai encore un
petit moment des cartes
on vient faire un étau sur cinq jeux du
mois fans même si
même si bien sûr ses mimiques de
l'analyse et à la maison après la
reprise cette fois le ps condamne je
n'ai pas de partir mais c'est déjà été
joués alors il est clair que
avant de rendre le
méli-mélo que philibert le dopage ne
travaille
plus
vraiment
et wasquehal chine il n'est pas parti
pour ces deux romans j'ai une collection
de fois il va le développer dans la
grande vague en cadeau il profite aussi
du fait que le fou de cases noires de
bord a disparu qu'il a plus de visas vis
fout là il se dit que dans la grande
diagonale il rayonnera d'autant plus
espions fait ça qu'on pourra peut-être
récupérer un jour tranquille monde est
une dame avec une tour mais surtout
embêtant poelvoorde a good stuff on va
vous aider problème au blanc pour
essayer de le défendre avec une
construction de pions
voilà avec la donc logiquement déjà
je compte bien
donc on va voir
beulin a priori est peut-être décédé
dans cette partie abandonnée c'est fou
et jouer avec ses chevaux
notre ami prague
bien sûr ces cases l'acquis son
importance et
sa lunette kms est vrai dans des
internats raison si on regarde la cab
carrière j ai alors ultra concentré
alors qu'on est encore dans la phase
d'ouverture où souvent les gens les
joueurs roannais attitude un peu plus
désinvolte l'aï la tête entre les mains
et peut-être qu'il a aujourd'hui des
ambitions vraiment d'aller chercher la
victoire avec les noirs oui c'est que
prague a perdu quand même un certain
nombre de parties attendra donc pourquoi
pas
puis en bus pour lui il a un style qui a
rien qui pourrait compter celui de
l'opposition de style a dans cette
partie il a joué d'avancé cette
immunisation sur l'opium et c'est aussi
intéressant parce qu'on aurait pu
imaginer
également de la part des blondes
pourquoi pas une construction comme ça
avec infirme qu'eto'o est le fou dans la
grande diagonale pour taper
il ya en même temps et que j'ai trois
ont solidifié
le pion au f4 mais maintenant que le fou
est parti en bessin il se dit bah
peut-être si tu fais j'ai trois pour
défendre ton toussaint à
cabinda
dans ma cave j'aime bien en défendre le
pion à la dame que j'ai trois fards à
joue également et la mule en détail on
imagine en rythme en vain mot alors
écoute ouais j'ai coupé désolé mais je
le comprends en fait pourquoi waouh
réfléchi car équipe comme ça c'est parce
qu'ils s'y prennent le trophée louis
cavaliers b3
donc sûrement sur des décès le
potentiellement il donne ce tube et il
peut récupérer celui là il a des thèmes
assez bien sûr par rapport à ce cavalier
bs avec tout de suite dans une position
très concrètes il ya des choses à
calculer quoi
et un coup comme
l'option
permet et après
donc maintenant je crois oui
je le vois pas aurel bgc pense pas
oui six bagues c'est qu'à la case des 4
et 15 g5 qui sont disponibles à créer
viens voir aussi décidé de vous moquer
de vendre ce pion peut-être
ses passions pc de s'activer je voulais
vous je voudrais par exemple cinq firmes
comme ça joue avec les deux foulées
colonne d'eau verte en disant que t'as
pas encore ok
je sais pas
kassav a déjà un faux mouvement et des
terminaux à la toile et vous lever il a
tenu le nul au mans c'est sûr
qu'après par l'ordre peut-être que kelly
b 3
ouais moi dans ma base qui est pas très
gros ce mets à base en ligne la gkb 3
jamais vu encore donc cette position
tout cas même je pense qu'elles existent
déjà ratio avec des outils plus jeunes
important mais c'est quand même un bon
indicateur que ça existe c'est très rare
comme il est donc vraiment intéressant
dans cette position à bakou trouve à la
ccara qu'il a fléchi ray on y reviendra
qu'est ce qu'est ce que tu as envie
d'aller voir
alors je prends beaucoup de changements
même parti mais
on va y avoir guéri jean claude
c'est la fête de la divette y voilà
séguéla des plans
nous envoie pas du rêve alsacien comme
avant
de même je connais moi avec les blu à
aïda
c'est vrai moi je suis très content
quand on blesse le centre avec les actes
et noir le plancher gagné sept petits
roquets bah du coup j'ai des plans pour
que c'est une bonne nouvelle à la
journée tu peux en bourse bière devant
l'échiquier pour les blancs avec les
noirs assez heureux
ça joue sur trois rangées à régir il a
peur de sortir de chez lui là je pense
qu'il a un petit peu paraguay avec la
coved hanister ouhlala faut surtout pas
que nos pièces entrent en contact je
reste tranquillement au final trois
rangées je veux pas dire le mans
il ya
six axes avant pas mal
démarré dans
mes bras
salut à toi
ici ok ça me semble moi j'aime bien
quand même des péchés de rockers genre
de positions mais on va faire confiance
à assam shankland des fois ci le point
peut venir aussi 6,1 pour consolider des
jeux le conte le faut
mais du coup un grillage lieu
4l une proposition d'échangé d'armes
champions dit là les noirs et gris pas
ok tu penses que tu vas me battre dans
cette position au courage en
tout les cas
je mette la caméra de thierry pourvoir
se tient droit commun a dit sur sa
chaise
en
3e
[Musique]
moi je sais pas il va jouer qui m'oblige
ou c3
jerry rappelle john remportait trois
parties d'affilée même si la première
comme caruana où ils étaient ni deux il
a bénéficié d'une énorme gaffe toujours
américain la seconde où bob s'est pas
présenté devant l'échiquier donc
l'allier par forfait et avant le cerf
avant dire moi il a fait mais il avait
montré une belle idée qu'on ne reste
plus qu il faille et une belle partie
d'un petit point fr 1 400 la suite ici
ce qu'ils ne renonceraient quand même
tous toute première place du tournoi
il faut le voir sur le papier qui est à
sa portée et champlain mais il n'est pas
venu avec en tout cas le
jeu peu d'ouverture agressive de
l'histoire d'un échec
général
maintenant on était 3 ou amplifiant
patinoire de
galles et
le
chevalier a coiffé de
2,3
une belle idée va que et peignoirs
peut-être que vous êtes vous gagnez de
verser 6 à ce moment là c'est pas
définitive n'y a pas de plus on sait 5
voilà les noirs les blancs bruns
d'avantagés comme je pensais ça
puisqu'il vrai trou là le vinci au
complet
avec les noirs ce genre de joueur il va
sûrement voir wimbledon fait retour des
8 ici
j'ai beaucoup de mal à voir comment tu
s'attendre à quelque chose avec les
blancs ici un endettement
le camion mais au moins lui la
voie de règlement tu peux attaquer le
bureau quatre chiens je parle de trucs à
innover cool ici
ce rush trois tailles warsak on fait le
calcul ouais il pas être embêté hockey
des
allemands voilà pourquoi pas
fait l'objet d'un bail en pression et de
fermer que le vent est mauvais dans le
oui pour la galerie pas débile non plus
haut mais je sais pas
bref si t'es pas obligée de le faire
soit pas forcément le faire mais
bon
bah moi aussi
autre que l'avesnois c'est bolloré pour
5h parti va rien se passer je suis un
petit peu d'être maîtres pas à la fois
content en misant robin jeu port
d'orange les quoi ça va être chaud
du coup je pense qu'on va pas on va pas
s'attarder sur cette partie au robinet
[ __ ] s'il se passe des trucs mais il a
choisi le plus direct d'attaquer les
pions il va sur voirie des deux je pense
ouah je crois
ouais
donc quelqu'un une position plus sympa
trouve
au rejet de chez migros d'elle jusqu'à
rhône a pas mal de coups et justement la
position intéressante va nous apporter
pourront tourner expertise sur une
française choisie par carvalho
leucate si c'était l'année des sacs et
donc comme la liste houphouet 5 c'est la
barre et monde d'avant la france est en
berne sur quatre est en théorie ya plein
de possibilités pour les blancs même la
française des changes on veut jouer bon
sans risque il a joué cinq grandes est
juste attaque à dire la production des
joueurs en scène avec les blancs tu sens
qu'il veut c'est gagner
en fait la côte notamment et
on la voit pas souvent
donc voilà un problème en vérité des
faits et en faut deux dans le fou il
serait mieux cette diagonale mais
par rapport à ilonse faire attaquer une
allure des quatre clubs du coup il dans
scénario pour m 2
l'idée souvent voyagé mais qui peut
arriver il faut comprendre est en fait
très souvent et jean le tronc des quatre
grands pays les champs
ou des effets oui la
dette est le prénom le pion bas il en
prit après il ya eu des vents souvent ou
en fait on ne peut donner le pion des
cas et même le pion de 5
c'est un peu osé mais willis fait donc
s'il n'y a pas cette tactique
mais met donc du coup on et toulouse
normalement en deux
ans maintenant et donc moi -
monnet-paquet je connais pas non plus je
vois pas d'où parle d'amour avec les
blues seraient que je connais pas très
bien
pour champion des besoins va
généralement on va d'abord le débat les
enquêtes publiques
et aux supporteurs de foot
et bien sûr je pourrais pas que des
neuf
points sud mais
maintenant cavalier et à fait normal
et du coup tout comme m donc
oui je sais qu'un cavalier polisse ça
vous parle qui est vrai ou
souvent ça peut être utile d'avoir un
défenseur potentiel pour le paiement des
cartes petit rock a été choisie
cavaliers g6 par par deux
ou trois fois
vous aussi être fini juste son
développement car il est b d2 et petit
rock ont même pour carole et c'est vrai
que pour
j'imagine car monnier va vouloir s est
de faire cette m6 puisque selon fu bah
c'est le fameux dilemme de la française
bonjour aux 6 au premier coup et nous on
se bloque et on a un mauvais coup de
quatre branches avec les noirs c'est
vraiment le problème principal des noirs
de cette ouverture s'il en fût était
paraît parfois au fc pour s'échanger
avec une faux détroit où des fois il ya
le faire bien à 6 vous serez assez
content mais là c'est pas le cas donc on
va voir quelle plante des noirs ici mais
avec la fermeture du centre ont fait est
que ça donne aussi des perspectives d'
attaque pour les blondes
ouais on va bien voir généralement un
rpg 3 3
où on le sent pas comme leroy revient
sur mêlée boutavant baignoire loin et le
bienveillant et malade et donc on vivant
entre la vallée
avaient
ouvert un peu plus m
l'amant
f au delà il est donc normal de voir
très souvent eu des cavaliers est un
canal étroit et m'a clairement jan
depoorter et du coût
pouvant
alors plusieurs choses
et souvent
avec comme d'un bébé pour aller manger
rebecca et des fois mais la meilleure
défense 3 et en gros du coup là on les
dit n'importe quoi
donc du coup
au dessus de la cave la kasbah iii ne
pourra plus jamais être autorisé
pour fouetter vallier et il y a plein
d'idées donc j'avais déjà vu une partie
3-2 à damas avec les blancs pitié adams
georges kleinmann onglets sur le trouve
deux sur le circuit malheureusement
donné beaucoup de joie
mais oui bof à importer des années et
n'ont pas aimé
il y avait une barre à
david et à donc de bloquer donc soit
vous l'avez vous cavaliers en b3
ou en fait l'idée comme prévu d'arriver
dans
le canal et b un cavalier à croire qu'à
valider et
sanction dérive tout ça permet de
dérouiller un petit peu là elle d'armes
avec les bleus on a dit qu'on voulait
jouer plutôt maladroit et si on arrive à
bloquer ce cavalier qui serait quand
même intéressant il bloque la colonne b
il défend des quatre hommes c'est que
c'est un peu à part peut-être que
certains lieux avec client grand bain ou
bravo si nous perdons sebha
mais
après un coup comme je prends des câlins
et demi en bd canal carrément si la
différence est que les noirs ils sont
déjà placés pour y aller ou d'un coup
alors que nous sommes bien cette salle
est donc
le foot
elle donc
donc voila apres à 4 et 2
une fois le fou mais on verra aussi
donc la pointe donc à bien
ok bah écoute a quant à lui s'il a
choisi plutôt à 3 à la place
la rue et là j'ai sûrement ripper
lassitude americom stouff pourtant du
coup lui veut prendre le contrôle de la
case la case bk te comparer cinq années
50 elle met forcément à chaque fois
qu'on fait ces petits pions sur l'ale
c'est toujours une concession qu'on
avance noir ou l'autre aura forcément
affaiblie rdda du côté qu'on ne protège
plus et de gros jouant à 3,20 il a fait
un faux sur canal plonge le gardera
s'est empressé de sécuriser en avançant
lui-même sur le pion score à 4 est donc
ce qu'on peut imaginer des fois il peut
y avoir une cire de ces cases qui vont
être exploitable il fixe aussi la tv sur
b2
sur un trois en fait la menace des
blancs auraient pu dépend
donc troqué le pion par feu
le mois de mai après les b4g à quatre
pions
comprises ne sait le talent à sa
réflexion mentionné des voix c'était une
idée
ok ça lui coco l'asticot
et
on nage ou des trois de grandes nageuses
donc c'est logique les redéploie sont
fous dans la pm diagonale maintenant que
la plus probable au centre parce que
logiquement avec les blancs comme tu
l'as dit va peut-être avoir un plan
d'attaqué moi j'aime bien les blancs
dans l'opposition parce que même si avec
les noix retard d'un peu de pression
d'avoir si carla il envoie son tube elle
pas
ici c'est de mettre de la pression sur
b2 mais ça me semble
pas si dur à maîtriser pour les pour les
blancs
ouais c'est genre de positions que je
trouve plutôt attrayante à jouer en tout
cas du côté de grandes villes us quoi
toujours plus sympa d'attaquer le roi
plutôt que tu faire attaquer son al-dam
mais après c'est une histoire de date
limite est aussi un de type de position
qu'on aime jouer
et
oui tout à fait
bon bien sûr la position un peu près
gars normal que les joueurs soient
assorties de l'ouverture et son jeu des
pauvres s'ils sont normaux
plus blanc mais
doit un beau combat en tout cas c'est
caruana qui avait fléchi ici on a bien
fait le tour pour l'instant de 2,7 de
cette petite française
et donc je te propose qu'on allait voir
on n'a pas encore dieu
peut-être lettre apporte dit j'ai
l'impression qu'on a
énormément de coups mais peut-être une
position petit peu atypique et john ware
très arrosé
de bons rapports et blanc
n'est pas très fébrile à le quesnoy
c'est vrai c'est vrai que toi et aux
rails et que son coût de jouer rapporte
très souvent joué des parties où les
deux joueurs se retrouvent à réfléchir
énormément dans l'ouverture ou sauver
entre quinçay notamment contrainte ragga
à chaque fois ou deux pas de d'une heure
de jeu a laissé un goût de jouer parce
que baïlador sortir des sentiers battus
et j'ai l'impression alors que ici ça a
l'air relativement standard a très vite
la position est devenu bizarre et c'est
vrai que après quatre coups dorment
allemande à notre première migraine ici
là vaut mieux être bien rentré dans sa
partie parce que quand on a quatre qui
ont deux centraux or visa à vivre parce
tomber vos calculs et qui mange quoi où
comment dans quel sens s'est tout de
suite prise de tête à cette position
on va essayer de comprendre avec vous je
passe que dans votre chatte si vous avez
d'ailleurs si ça nous arrive d'avoir ce
genre d'opposition avec des petits
carrés de bureaux au centre comment vous
en sortir en général ce que vous
calculez les p o dia les coûts d'emprunt
ce qui se passe
alors du coup quelle idée puisque
al'avantage pouvoir aux pressions savoir
l'intérêt quand même steph dans ce que
vous choisirez six éoliennes de jouer
curieusement
[Musique]
je vais t5 coquet et en fait on pas du
coup on en est pas encore arrivé
et je me dis que
[Musique]
ça me paraît logique le sien j'aurais
dit la même chose que toi
bois pesant rescousse d'un candidat tu
donnes un pion sacrifions pour éloigner
le pion central des noirs et toi même
peut-être pour le centre et dire que tu
vas récupérer plus tard c'est possible
on peut récupérer directement ma mission
veut c'est pas forcément l'idée
donc c'est la première possibilité à
regarder pour les noirs et là aussi ça
ouvre bien sûr le four qui devrait
rendre l'accès certainement l'idée de
une des grandes idées de ce coup de
rapports
et raccords du coup il a joué l'autre
prise de pions
s'éprend douleur
est là rapport et il en a rien à [ __ ]
ils ne reprennent pas et il continue son
développement
et j'aime bien la bbc ouais
avec le déclic à l'écran
est là
[Musique]
donc
c'est pas si grave qu'on de fermer ce
faux pas ce que pourra sûrement leur
actif est assez facilement plus tard oc
c est un peu ce qu'ils peuvent cette
position
est apprise en passant en béton
oui
j'étais un petit peu mais pas si facile
sa naissance en tout cas
mais il n'a pas trouvé ça rapporte quand
bizarrement finalement peut-être y avait
kamel jamais trois
pardon je réduis dans la vente
ok
mais reddition
ou de 4 à 2 au match est restée invité
chez les dames fonctionnement à la
baisse avec rapport à guérir c'est pas
c'est pas forcément le même style de
joie
qu'il a lu tous cavaliers 3 il va
récupérer maintien il reprend maintenant
avec la dame du parce que
là on pouvait l'attendre peut-être
donc oui et non juste pour montrer sipa
le cavalier maintenant qu'apple cinq
cavaliers va devoir bouger on espérer
changer l'avant se faisant des rockets
donc c'est pas rater nation pour les
blancs
du coup il a pris la dame bat non
d'un compte validé
fin qu'après et le monde vu sur l'avant
de développement avant garde la vallée
prendre l'allée des sphinx ou et 4
et
le pion
à 3 il y en a une vraiment
de voir que la récession s'est
elle-même même si les dames ont disparu
de l'échiquier a connu contrairement au
pouvoir raciste kerry ya un peu plus de
vie dans cette position parce qu'il ya
des thèmes 1 pour essayer d'exploiter
justement le léger retard de
développement des noirs en compensation
du pion qui ont sacrifié doigt c'est
beaucoup plus déséquilibré pour moi
symétrique
donc oui l'idée lui est encore
intéressant de rapports de l'ouverture
qui
il a pas il appelle changé d'âme encore
visite il peut ne pas échanger les dames
d'ailleurs quelques coups candidats par
la prise et si tout ça ne semble pas si
évident
que ces six
il reprenne du cavalier
est-ce que ça a du sens pas sûr le
c-17 oui
je joue
ah non il y aura une carrière
peut-être
qui sait si c'est
pour nous élever des trois vallées
yade à bassac échec à l'idée de tout
face était de faire de preuve cette matt
cooke à un piège de type x toof
si vous voyez est rentré dans le groupe
et contrôlent une partie pédagogique ou
quoi baissier vous souvent il ya une
idée de bâton d'un coup une petite scène
ou de fourchette
c'est bon c'est pas net
mais ici c'est réfuté
le monde
donc ok choix intéressant pour arbres
oui c est ce qui va changer les dames ou
pas moi je pense que oui puisque les
autres options paraissent super naturel
mais c'est qu'on a envie aussi des temps
sur cette dame blanche anglais mais ça
paraît pas si facile
ok on va voir ils n'ont joué que six
coulées de loire
ils prennent leur temps
alors qu' on dépend encore y avoir ce
tournant même pu en revanche rappelé
la ministre ignore
comme on en voit assez souvent j'ai
l'impression
avec détroit donc à menchhoffen l'homme
qui marche à
pied caractérisé la part de sacrifice du
pion des noirs juste pour montrer
rapidement
ici de noir sacrifice pions wah wah
wah un peu d'attaquants suis dit bon je
me fous des six pour chasser la tour
damage quatre fous j'ai gardé choses
d'où ils ont leurs pièces qui vient
attaquer le roi blanc ces dépositions
moins intéressant dès qu'ils sont sur
rade alizés qui même très souvent au nul
en ligne jusqu'au centième but théorie
et passe ça devient très compliqué pour
les blancs de gagner de prendre
davantage à ce niveau sur cette
ouverture c'est pourquoi maintenant à la
porte en fait à chaque crise parce qu'on
appelle des antilles marshall ou comme
des trois hommes à quatre on a vu
notamment dans le choix du monde en
plein ça des dépôts comme h
3o éviter de rentrer dans cette variante
est joué une partie
bah oui six pattes des choses sur le
long terme notre cas soit moins par son
coin
c'est honda les manoeuvres typique de
hesbignonnes stouff à aigle blanc but
even the wild cat un moment donné
et les doigts ils prennent de l'espace à
l'état mais il s'entraîne au four qui
recule et où je sais ce que c'est une
position dont j'ai déjà lu avec les
noirs à l'époque je jouais cinq
incertain deux fois
je bats c'est bien
il revient ici ça maintenant qu'il a
fait son taf
à 3 aura toujours utile parce que c'est
toujours embêtant se faire clouer ici
tout type y trouve des espagnols ces
sales
pattes on me when ont fait mal au delà
de m hollande et m mais je suis souvent
lieu dans le port
du voile à
sec te ment
petites et très petites
réactions de votre phrase standard aussi
qui veut casser un peu la dame à 4
dont kkr a eu des cas une décade pour
fermer
db4 coupable m et 41 cents est clair
maintenant et à ouvrir le foot en fait
deux le foot en b3 et reebok ou wire
brûlant des deux points et il est venu
en france les deux rives enfin jean
pierre vallet a faim et le trou le prix
millions 2 mais maintenant que l'ubs et
4 à evreux dans l'eure et loir que dans
deux coups et ben 23 qu'il est reparti
et on prend b3 parce qu'au final elle
était une très très belle les cadres les
planches et bien ouvert est vrai que les
noirs ont du mal
attention que le contrepartie henry
champions peut donner des cales et
d'affaiblir un peu plus
près le
les quatre maintenant les blancs peuvent
retourner
philippe sion ne recule pas donc à
chaque coup de pions et définitive c'est
une grosse décision après qu'est ses
cannes à saint loup pierre a vendu toute
sa structure sur casse noix ici
on trouvait les cases vierges
yapluka vaya
donc pouvait trois exactement vous
pouvez 3 le retour on reprend la belle
diane nous attendons à ce que ce fou
l'isf associés contre est ici courbet
vite tomber vite ce qui m'agace présent
cette fois pas pour l'instant puisque la
dame défend donc ya pas de
drame des convertis siens
du coup pour mon pays est vide c'est
quoi l'idée de tourner vite
- c'est sur le long terme juste sacrée
des termes sur cette colonne
et on est dans cette position dont
quelques bonnes phases qui doit jouer à
bois une position qui répétait une bière
est caractéristique de l'espagnol il ya
toujours des petites nuances ou partie à
l'autre on va voir comment comment ils
décident de jouer ce qui si
malheureusement des quatre ce qui va
redéployer son cavalier vais regarder
sans que personne ne vienne pas me dire
qu'en fait les 12 f1 ça paraît bizarre
mépris de mon véhicule
pourquoi parfois fait là
j'aimerais bien la chasse aux cavaliers
de bellepierre
mais le québec va contrôler la case
départ or en gros une idée intéressante
pour les blanches qui délimitent cavalli
est un parfait pouvoir mener
tranquillement pour rassemblement sur la
place des jeunes gens qu'on aime ou
qu'on regardait a lieu trois quarts aile
et diakhaté et voyez que maintenant plus
qu'une pièce des noirs ou à venir
contrôler et aimant travailler le four à
venir embêter
champions bien sûr je pense que
maintenant j'ai envie
du tout
car il aurait la classe des faits et
avoir un niveau de la couture et tout
mais l'idée cette aide m soit le fond on
est cinq fois cavalier en effet pour
vraiment expliquer le deschamps tailler
la haie voyant d'être là
trois pièces un donc le four b3 le
cavalier 3 est aussi cavalière froid qui
pourra un jour donc invalide ligue 2 les
caf e3 où cavaliers des 2 es1 es3 et
plusieurs chemins pour les grands
desseins n'aurait de trois pièces
potentiel savaria l'état alors que les
noirs donc deux pièces au dossier du
club défendre l'idée je vais
encore en cavale et fous moi on va
prendre une bonne place en f1
c'est ce que veut dire c'est que le rêve
le rêve des blancs dans cette position
de cette complication satde de faire
disparaître ça le chic et ses quatre
pieds cela est comme ça on se
retrouverait poursuite avec
avec le bon cavalier qui nous pourrait
viser la cades et 5 contre en [ __ ]
casar qui serait mauvais puisque il tape
terre derrière sa structure de piau il
ay la touche est long sur noir donc se
fout c'est un peu un gros plots dans
cette position donc largement ça sera un
gros avantage stratégique pour les
blancs sauf que comme vous avez pu le
voir à ça prend énormément une coup
d'arriver à et et bien évidemment du
bois paul il est malin il fera tout pour
que ça n'arrive pas mais ça peut être un
plan en tout cas mais c'est du très long
terme donc donc à voir si celui de
choisir une forêt n'a pas de possibilité
dans cette position qui est très riche
encore
nous reste qu'à aller voir peut-être
femmes d'où des spéculations partie puis
on retourne à vincelles puisqu'on était
qu'au tout début
on n'est pas les voir
mêlés voir notre but n'est pas bien sûr
une chose pareille du master's d'abord
doodle shipping co une position que
votre intervention toshi
duda
qui participent à la dea et jouer des
quatre boudent-ils bourse tombant du
haut doubs darryl ah
oui là il était plutôt bien parti et
derrière
on s'est rappelé de il arrive à gratter
fait non la paire du coup de carmona
avec outre
qu'il a perdu et complet mais diawara
way et là il ya les bons coups c'est une
bonne occasion pour lui de se relancer
car mon
ampli que le père d'ailleurs
avec les blancs
et des bouquets
à données sont fous de gaz noirs ici
moi je n'aime pas trop cette décision
ça c'est bien sûr encore une fois on
déroulait dans des sphères ouais c'est
pas d'app est ultra jouer dans cette
position c'est pepsi
typique
vidéo
dès maintenant on a en fait
donné la main et ont retrouvé quatre ans
donc le plan libéral a envoyé un village
au défi
heavy julio
a pris le blâme et m il est bon la
rénover mais là c'est d'oser
gravats qui traînerait raison verbaux de
vote aux élections de duda
marché les ce2 et
l'amener à quesnoy et un nouveau tube
aux nouvelles cartes blanches et on joue
avec la couleur de coups qu'on possède
3 et 3
5 sur 5 on va bouger pour bien sûr pas
mon genre
non je sais pas vous
mais bon tu rencontres avant tout cas le
raku noire va être
annoncée bien je pense que c'est
maintenant c'était la fée spectre et que
je t'ai pas fan dans la passe mais où il
n'a pas fait ça en l'air il a une idée
derrière fait si c est du coup ça fait
sens en tout cas vraiment une partie a
dit merde sur la d re composé notamment
puisque même le bois bleu blanc qui il
s'est un petit peu découvert et de petit
affaiblissement
dati va envoyer aussi duché cats il est
noir on tirera pas ça peut ça peut
chauffer mon avis dans cette partie des
stocks
du coup aller voir partir de rien
et après europe londres ap allez sur 400
vraiment qu'au tout début
alors marc andré
yakhya les pièces blanches ou comme on
l'a dit en tout lieu de stream pour ceux
qui nous rejoignent contre le petit
frère de jordan forest lukas
avant d'écarter cinq
candidats acceptés
je récupère son pion directement ça doit
rire on le sait son équipe à bahreïn
pour essayer de mettre l'impression à
son
petit rock
à 6
4 tout moche et que c'est pas ton
répertoire beaucoup plus 1000 tyrannie
du mien
je pars à ce que pense le café est
connue ce que c'est en tout cas l'idée
intéressante c'est qu'elle est l'idée du
coup sûr quel point le 4 nov je sais
quand même en sacrifice de pions et
depuis en sens
inverse
le
gabon qui veut jouer sur ce vis-à-vis
admettons pourra
peut-être cavaliers bouche du court et
là on verrait des 5 et tout de suite ça
a créé des gros problèmes au droit
option sera attaqué
au foie et 10 kg scène car il est le
retard du développement ici serait
compliqué à gérer
avec les blancs mais on a quand même de
plus en plus à la tour le fou sortis et
ont plus droit
ouais
pas mal
d'appréhension et la coque donc après
d'ailleurs dangereuse 1 et du coup il
sait quoi lescure et commet 5 et bosh
assez bien pour illustrer vous avez
surtout quand vous avez les choses si ce
n'avait pas encore évoqué même jour là
pour la tête déjà dit c'est le plomb f
comme faut pas toucher
au but raté stuff
l'ouverture sacré vraiment trop de trous
cette diagonale notamment meurtrière
trop de faiblesses de partout ici ça
serait très dangereux et on aurait pu
garder nos jeunes cavalières en fait je
pense pour exploiter tout ça
j'ai pas quel serait le meilleur suisse
y est peut-être pour jouer simplement
des cinq et sept fois
et par dieu
juste voir par rapport à la crise ici
mais
j'ai
trois contre trois voilà plus que le
regarde
on aime changer une pièce table de deux
fois contre une quête de pouvoir tarek
ben
oui mais les trois permis ont acheté un
bon bah moi qui
ai
[Musique]
pas ma voix est là il ya eu quatre ports
terme à tous les fans on va croire ça
fait peu d'illusions je pense elle est
catastrophique
y'a que des coups de pioche et noir est
encore une fois le meilleur coup j'y
serai pouvoir actuel pur drame espion s
est donc
ch pour ses quelque chose d'instructif 1
pour rousset attention sur est vraiment
et éviter de l'avancé en début de partie
donc vous n'avez pas loupé mm pour vous
avez voté faites attention à cette
diagonale qui s'ouvre c'est vraiment
quelque chose il ya beaucoup de parties
jouées même jusqu'à un niveau correct
sur ces choses là donc pas m'en faire
très attention à ça pas se montrer trop
gourmand et du queen's il n'a pas pris
le pion
n'a pas pris joann sfar s il a eu peur
certainement de touche contre jeu et
peut-être qu'il connaît aussi me la
jouer à la place plus que cinq
maintenant parlons b5 d'ajouer lcd blanc
conjointe les cinq
là ils essaient tout forage de l'ong
hockey
clairement
que
pas
peut imaginer mais on peut supposer qu
on peut même espérer pour lui puisque 6
à 5 aux nets ça peut être
bien
que non c'est quoi j'étais capable
ap la femme qui fait qu'il
a connu
trois mais je crois pas je
l'aï récemment des compositions
mais bon ils ont fait le point des trois
inspecteurs et par
les quatre à manger et qu'il blaguait
découvert qu'on récupère d'ailleurs
mais bon
à présent d'en bas enfin il n'aurait pas
eu leurs thèses
ont mangé le temps passait bien en moins
la part de food
ouais bon repas chauds récupère un pièce
d'ailleurs plaint de conflit en termes
de piau et laver chez six avec les noirs
keller très logique parce que nouveau
les pions certes mais déjà en revanche
berlin sont donc c'est pas des trous va
doubler isoler rodin un trio des
compactes ici contrôle de quatre
centrales où c'est intéressant et
surtout souffre on ouvre la colonne g
sur ce roi où ça peut être dangereux et
on a en tout cas tu manges tu vas tu en
perds ma première ne l'aiment pas du
tout les bordeaux
tu va taper dans cette diagonale
et la paire de fois la position est
ouverte pète les plombs et d'une
meilleure structure qu'elle est elle
même ces cinq
là leur vision une meilleure structure
vision purement je suppose et qu'il ne
leur est pas j'ai dix ans après -6 afu
procès soit cas c'est pas acté
voit cette position que je prends
beaucoup plus agréable pour les noirs
jeudi avec la paire nous faut des lignes
ouvertes écolo d'ouverte
leroy istres à l'abri au centre
finalement
pas du tout convaincu par cette idée ne
sait pas à quel point c'était ça tu sais
pas où je pas qu est ce que tu en penses
qu'est ce que les mêmes d'ailleurs il
est intéressant n'est-ce pas le dire si
vous perdez plutôt jouer ça par exemple
avec les blancs et les noirs voient ce
que vous en pensez et donc stouff douadi
nous déjà
bas sans faute calment les blancs
pareillement
la maman et
le plomb en italie il a l'avantagé 8
déjà empêche cavale est compté car
croire
donc du coup tu fais pas bougé 3 ok on
restera un budget pour un jour dans ce
genre de positions non
un schéma mais je pense qu'on soit
obligé un jour où j'ai travaillé blanc
n'a pas tout de suite on a
sinon n'arrive pas à se défaire de cette
problème ici
bas / -
f2 à la plage
située sur gc ca ici
la vallée de
tavannes point ici alors qu'il avait
engagé trois
leur couple est
donc à devoir
dans les allées je pense que de raison
c'est celle de la qualité de
jeu 3
il faut être fin était proche pareil
pour la cave des films tellement
touchante et la perte de but faut
stabiliser on verra pour le coup de
meilleures structures et on pourra jouer
dessus donc j'aime beaucoup ton était la
callas d2 qui a l'art de soulager pas
mal de problèmes des blancs du
hockey d'atikokan faut des chemins ou
avoir une position intéressante mais
boue
noire ait choisi pour me changer d'âme
ouah ouah à ce qui se passe passe et une
position intéressante en
tête et il est vrai
beaucoup
ok bah je propose avant de faire une
première pause de quand même retourné
sur 400 ce qu'on avait à peine eu lieu
c'est quand même important tous les
jours
quand tu es
tombé mais le
petit road petit rock qu elle va y
arriver le froid nous a juste dit
solidifie se concentre est ce que vous
utilisez ce fameux tour à 6
est ce que est ce que c'est une nouvelle
idée histoire si j'ai l'impression que
c'est peut-être une petite botte secrète
cac a lâché ben ahmed europe
pas du tout mais en fait
les deux mois de cavale
et
avant qu'on décale des ponchos
et maintenant
tout
est
il ya eu un peu froid provoque emmanuel
5 donc non pour enlever son cavalier ou
cinq tours à bureaux au moins eu la tour
dont suspension
est en fait ben
jamais pareille je passe partie dans la
base mon grain de voix c'est une
base c'est la 5ème justement mais de
joie ça doit quand même pas si fréquent
moi ça que tu as pas avoir déjà vu cette
idée on va bien sûr dans d'autres
positions qui peuvent ressembler belle
précisément aux candidats
je suis pas dû vraiment pas du tout à me
faire à cette filature
tout ça très intéressant et à raison et
on a pu voir c'est ce qui s'est passé
donc d'amener de pointe agression et
banon sperme et p5 alors j'aime aller en
1 4 et effectivement je crois même temps
qui va suivre
tout de suite cassé
et donc ouest où va-t-on je te fait
perdre une seconde je me disais
mais les noirs
par ses assistants qu'un pour consolider
la structure
important aussi juste pour montrer il
n'y a pas de cloison ici bien sûr on est
défendue et même deux fois il n'y a pas
de problème
dans les colonnes a
donc sur celles ci ciciba grâce à la
joue et je pense que trilogiq et ses 3
poursuit son développement et met la
pression de nouveau sur b 5
kgs en suisse et une idée avec to b 6
très logique du coup très très bonne
cette cité de médias rendent c'est
intéressant de savoir à quel point ces
nouveaux
mais
j'aime beaucoup
ils attendent plus un rappel ou a
peut-être oublié du cloud mais sa frappe
est stable acceptez donc on a mangé un
pion et si time à consolider attention
ensuite rassuré encore des compensations
pour les blancs c'est une position
l'écart celle d'envoyer eu quatre
dons qui change un peu son souci des
poules ils voient qu'il peut pas
récupérer les pions donc qui va prendre
l'espace au centre va libérer aussi s'en
fout il peut créer des thèmes lui sur
cases noires
des fois des médias dès 5 ans que je
passe pour accessoires possible mais ça
peut exister dans la position aussi une
tour carrée elle notamment
il faudra venir celle du coup c'est quoi
l'idée de jouer beckham
d'après toi
l'avalée des avalés en p4 oui
mais des cavaliers detroit
ouais c'est vrai on s'intéresse ans le
point principal de droit c'est de
développer ces pièces là surtout pour
l'instant car nous sommes au vcg
compensation blanche et se trouve aussi
à tanger par est mon second est ce que
bataille a pas plus bas 5 avons prises
c'est pas une gageure voire l'instant
n'a pas on n'a pas les ballasts des
ordinands conclure mais
au passage je vois que la petite barbe
blanche sur ce procès si tu es
tu as oublié le monde
sait que j'ai cherché pourquoi et je
veux demander ce n'était pas par rapport
à ce qu
on récupère a fait peut-être qu'il ya
des problèmes
je vois pas de découvertes et rexel tout
en tout cas
est-ce que b46
ça me pose vraiment problème houblon
depuis on est fragile au centre mais si
vous êtes mon dieu
je pense que ton bien ça ouais pas b 4
way we can pas mal
leur abattage à l'accueil des artistes
et six mois
avec un anneau arrière droit
au revoir montrer
leur fils a fait très mal
ouais c'est pas possible pour tout rond
qu'est ce que t'as pas des bonus est
complexe et
a fait la
différence trop avec option avec les
doigts même si on peut supposer il ya
beaucoup de pression sur son propre
risque même lui qui ont l'air de
récupérer en tête québec at ici les p4
tempe ou
17 août à dakar
cet
investissement va le perdre contre
le mal et on le paie cash voilà c'est
fait chaud c'est intéressant
je pense qu'il a prévu un média sûr je
pense qu'un cd trois quarts des
sacrifices tokyo
n'était pas possible jusqu'à lorsque le
fou défendez d'où ça vient de devenir
possible dans cette position
tu veut se reposer du coup quelques
jours dans leur s qatargas 2 5 derrière
ça change pas mal de choses pour être
recalculés
calais pas de calais prendre le micro
waouh à barbie stouff bien sûr
bien donne peut-être
pas
mérité cinq
essais pour placer ce que je veux dire m
cavalier rouge il a pas de découvertes
dangereuse puisque les casses crise
pourrait manger des quatre mais je vous
dis que la dame gardien déçu rachète
donc
donc surtout pas
et du coup si je comprends pas que leur
disent pas que ce soit que la barre 10
paxon millions pour les bleus sur vos
projets
non
mais
c'est quoi la barre qui dit juste un
petit avantage au blond seulement
une qualité d'être davance mais on
espère que ça c'est très fort
que lui est faible
des pièges du mal à jouer mais
c'est assez étonnant fait pas
l'impression que c'est son gagne ainsi 6
pas avoir ça m'étonnerait que le
baliseur que j'ai envie de rentrer
dedans même c'est petit même si les
créatifs
la
levée alors
leur indique où il peut parfois d'autres
sur eux sans qu'ils 17
c'est pas très bon
le père des femmes là
parce que tu proposes to pouvoir la paix
rhdp dirar d'autres champions du manque
de cube et il a bien raison
pat ont été instaurées par cette partie
va revenir après la pub on va voir parce
que c'est vraiment mon oncle est
justement qu'est-ce que je choisis car
celle ci ça a bougé au pouvoir obtient
de l'analyse ensemble
à la suite
[Musique]
et
il
[Musique]
et
en
[Musique]
à
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ans
[Musique]
on
mais de retour vous pourrez faire un
show avec 1025 parce qu'on a une partie
entre les deux leaders quand celle de
l'europe qui est en train de prendre une
tournure très excitante
pendant la pause
car c'est bien joué le coup on avait
mentionné finalement c'était eux 5
l'idée qu'avait trouvé stouff avec
notamment sur le thème va peut-être
surtout faire un seul ben deja il n'a
pas eu peur et avec amabilité cinq
candidats écoute je suis prêt à
sacrifier une qualité dont à regret
avant la pause en rapidement la prison
des 5 10 réalisent je remonte
donc filer la fois hélas de la mission
est 15e intercalé apprend b5
là maintenant et il se trouve qu'il ya
peut-être cavale il est fait entendre
leur juste pour montrer sur cette robe
et 5
bat il peut y avoir imaginé la même
label isr pourquoi mon crochet au cas où
[Musique]
on a des nouvelles personnes qui nous
rejoignent dame fance à perdre
immédiatement à cause de la machette
c'est le drame menaces de maths et elle
assure la dame
et est donc champion prime deux alliés
il y aurait cette fois un sac kelly
qualité pour les blancs
mais
mais ok peut-être que c'est pas si clair
quoique la barre elle s'affole pas tu
peux avoir la période de flou des
compensations pour la drogue plus
surprenante intéressante
mais le fait est que du coup ici
sur cette terre de 5 c'est la position
actuelle et sa valeur de jouer et
réfléchie pour une bonne raison c'est
comme s'il a mentionné il a peut-être
cavaliers bekaert intermedia
web d'un moule ne peut pas ou pour
attaquer la dame et du coup ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on suit
pas ça évite tout provient de mars
histoire de fou 3 5 mm ou cette dame
questions alors on aura
bien sûr
les ondes bcg 4 il souffre il veut
battait
old school
pas intéressé par les tubes tu veux
battre
le temps pour
la voir donc
où les canons quel goût du produit g6
obligatoire trop
cette fois je suis
bien oui c'est vrai des spams aussi que
quinzaine il rentre dedans
ses leaders
[Musique]
cette partie d'inspiration
j'aime bien le blanc comme ici
voici reboux j'ai tout de suite c'est
peut-être que le retrait du fou 17 oui
karim arrim en d3 les plans récupérer
leurs pions b tu veux dire je sur le
mois mais les droits ils ont aussi leur
des choses anormales manga
brain wave d'autres dédiés mamediarov du
coudon qu'il veut donner cet esprit
rentrer là dedans et que québec a
d'intermédiaire soit il décide de
poursuivre son idée de sacrifier la
qualité puisqu'il a permis pour
l'instant car elle n'a pas c'était de
rentrer dedans mais si on bloque et re
donne la possibilité à personne d'aller
manger la qualité des recettes sont
obligés de le faire mais ici c'est
qu'abbas et encore tu manges un pion et
une qualité qu'on va prétendre c'est
juste une gaffe est reparti parce que
les attaques et les beckham
bas du cookie et bekaert oui faire en
ville
et c'est vrai qu'en fait avec les pièces
blanches est pas si facile à défendre ce
pion le paquet pour rouler ici
interdisons
pas installer un cavalier la
fouge et catalyst injuste
ah ouais si je peux avoir quand même ces
trois pions lier ça peut être
intéressant
je vais pas obligés de manger je peux le
sujet est clos et pourquoi pas même si
tu n'en bête ne rapatrie dans cette aide
aux
enfants malades et leurs fameux 3
non croyant défendre m
c'est vrai que c'est ainsi qu'un boost
arrive pas exploiter cette corrida c'est
pas si facile pour le blond de faire
parler leurs qualités d'avant centre une
position étonnante presse que m6 serait
une idée pour les droits
réclamés à
faire
mais bon si on arrive à lui axé dans
d'autres conditions ce serait
intéressant mais ça va
exploser
wall street va devoir laisser aux médias
roch du poids peut-être que manager à
fos il s'attendait à
a donc assez indirectement on viens de
regarder
été surpris que qu'intel ne décide de
pas je te manquer c'est le matériel et
je pense qu'à mon avis avec sa nouveauté
un peu un peu raciste pour b6 magie
nouveaux élèves ont vérifié en tout cas
avec cette idée très originale il doit
avoir dans son âme ce genre
de sacrifices il a dû le voir dans ces
fichiers je pense pas que tu tu te
prennes sa siamo en fait si tu connais
pas tu connais pas tout et
c'est une tactique en deux coups sa
perte quoi aller mais cette analyse est
un peu la position avec 3 est d'avis
qu'en fait ça jouer
et donc que tu peux surprendre
l'adversaire
[Musique]
notre notre choc du jour qui nous déçoit
pas dans l'ouverture badia fidèle à lui
même toujours aussi créatif
bon allez c'est on va laisser réfléchir
prendre cette décision
et allait voir d'autres joueurs tout
qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui tente de lancer la réponse
je sente en réponse à des kilomètres ça
commence par rappeler ça tenait par la
main a
apparemment amené à
découvrir les petits princes guillaume
plus la position est intéressante dames
on se rappelle que l'ouverture déjà
il y avait des idées assez original
puisque prague estime laisser doubler un
pur pions
qu'on était resté ici à ce cavalier b3
book y avait
abaissé deux purs reprises et carnac et
nous qui était déjà la tête entre les
mains 25 me centrer pour essayer de
trouver le meilleur coup dans cette
position
donc ça va et là c'est le a6 bakar ou
qui fait 105 armand pour essayer de
forcer il faut à prendre une décision en
quelques mois
trois reprises indépendants n'y ont donc
en résolvant un problème et c'est ce qui
s'est passé dans la partie
a
donné
la balle est maintenant cette barre de
cavalli qu'entre les deux il fuit la
production allait fermer les dernières
des noms vous voyez que bon vraiment le
vouloir un point
et a
dominé avec les cavaliers genre
dépendre le cavalier et
1re tireurs tout va les cavaliers ont
bloqué un peu près car après tout il
intéressant mais c'est vrai pari
stratégique a fait draguer
la perte de chevaux entre la perte de
groof on va voir si ce pari s'avère
gagnant tu as dit la plus sûre été
fermés d'accord avec toi même si je ne
leur en serai en biseau sait pas non
plus où ils à la muraille de chine quoi
si je veux dire il ya des perspectives
d'ouverture les fouilles ou quand même
des diagonales paris d'intéressant
this way s'est pas
d'accord c'est pas une position ouverte
mais c'est pas non plus fous de la
française quoi
[Musique]
et je joue quand même si on peut le dire
sur les cases noires pour restaurer bons
rails c'est là où il a des appuis à
l'exception pour essayer d'installer ses
cavaliers plutôt sur place dehors et on
wheels à 1h24 à la porte de la gardienne
droit il a déjà 40 minutes de retard
donc lui les livres à lui même trac qui
est dans ses petits dans ses petits
souliers et c'est intéressant encore une
fois il ya peut-être avec le gros rock
plus tard qui sait puisque your h
le bar
est là en fait on comprend
donc les remous
et pour attaquer l le faire un ghetto
votre note qu'une foule cannois embêter
son vis à vis pas si facile non plus au
mieux à
chaud quand même d'accord parce que là
vraiment c'est le joueur la structure
d'objets oui c'est pas son problème est
ce qui l'intéresse c'est la dynamique
parce que mon potentiellement s.com se
faire tripler les pions
alors quoi elle parle beaucoup ramé 7
pour illustrer sa ouvré quand même des
colonnes pour pour le roi et aurait
certainement
f5 qui pourrait partir à juste pour
montrer aussi à cette ré c'est trop
c'est trop normes et les noirs ils
pourraient en cas d'approché 130 de la
torah ce football là c'était à rennes
pour rochette avec la tour l'alba john
jay sept tournois c'est d'avoir des mots
je tombe toute sa vie
mais l'idée n'est pas neuve
après
mais la
caf
et
de sacrifices
mais
juste pour dire des joueurs sais pas ce
qui s'est passé bien sûr c'est
intéressant je sais que c'est un pion
vous dire bravo foumban ont ils fait
blocus alors moi je pense que c'est
respectivement hodder on voit la barre
lors 10 février étaient très contents
ils voulaient - gestion
moi je pensais mais je vais sûrement de
faire réfuté du cloud pour s'adapter
pour essayer de juger quatre là
peut-être juste
brillé une fois on fait ça paraît pas
pour
mais il ya peut-être fois-çi ce métier
qui pose un problème sur ce pion voir f
s'imbriquent
et vous même si j'ai du mal à défendre
ce
problème en super g de framboises que
j'arrive pas logique arrêtez donc du
coup bon plan ne marche pas
et donc si belle aurait sûrement fait
drogue non j'imagine y en
a un ça va
la page est fort c'était quoi son dd
araxxe beau boulot ça vient de moi je
devrais pas de regarder avec les blondes
fitch et s&p qu'il va trouver les oublie
ici
c'est un endroit
alors attendre onze ouais je regardais
de la bonne foi c'est quoi ton dd
et le kayak puis j'ai fait un
tour bien je peux aussi te manger
maintenant dire maintenant j'arrive plus
à quoi nach l'exploit que jamais disons
je bouffe aux chevilles et 2
l'expression intéressant de regarder qui
nous propose lui de sacrifier la calotte
cheikh c'était nautique
de paume et vous que l'on pense et je
pense que la raison je pense que c'était
ça l'idée de prague
fait ses devoirs sur les cases blond je
serai ce qu'on fait qu'avaliser ça
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour moi qui se
trouvèrent groupe dab
sa vraie justice
c'est très intéressant et je pense qu'il
a eu peur de ça parce que la 106 une
prépa et du coup il s'est dit ouais ça
ça pue
et
de rejoindre
on a du mal à exprimer
les tours du mal à s'exprimer oui je
creuse pas si facile cavaliers
l'histoire des cas
c'est sûrement ça restait surtout
prudent
des retraites chapeaux qui chauffe
sacrifice
ou et kayak il il a joué à barra gare
magnifique c'est ce qui s'est passé avec
juste eu à cinq cas étaient intercalés
ou avoir gros spectacle dans cette
partie
pour balancer leur univers ouais
je voyais pas prague bat carré qui met
fin à balad première fois a les moyens
pour le fameux
parce que c'est beaucoup plus important
que le reste a bien raison
watson carla qui est un
des boutons croix chang de prague qui
est assis devant son échiquier qui a
envoyé sept pour un choc la
cabine qui revient d'une part klaus a
fait arriver peut-être des toilettes des
femmes à avoir
il a pris à tom boes vc attendre la
acide
impassible alary squale alors risk of
salue les ont pas loin qui arrive au
meilleur moment puisque on vient
d'assister un sacrifice de deux tours
pas de qualité de prague contre le
ministre de la défense on va voir s'ils
méritent encore son surnom nous parce
que l'alim à carnoët dans une situation
où va palois qui montre toutes ses
compétences sur un plan défensif
donc là il caffè - mais le pion
et apprendre à la
[Musique]
paix etc sur
la survie pc avec les deux rien pas y'a
pas droit à l'erreur c'est pas plan plan
et ouakam tout je m'interroge choix de
karuïa king qui me semble intuitivement
pas forcément pertinent d'avoir
intercalé à cinq cavaliers dégagé
l'impression que ça aide les bleus
jusqu'aux de choses puisque
quoi comme on vient de la grille alors
vous pouvez avoir ce la même chose
exactement comme ça et car jacking
dupuis l'estimé c'était mieux dans la
position
d'un témoin de la scène qui est des
quatre
mois ça sur la patrie logiquement
pas
leurs
noms mais qu'est ce que ça apporte
d'abord auteur de calais ça parce que si
tu veux rentrer là dedans dans son sac
et pis de qualité autant le faire avec
le cavalier qu'il est menacé par rapport
au roi
là il ya quand même déjà décalé
potentiel des cavaliers sa popote
sur première
la
plus élevée a déjà déclaré qu'il ne pas
être impassible alex davison
[Musique]
pour monter à 100 cette féroce sur
l'entrée des souvenirs
même dans un hommage sur ma du monde
contre gaza c'était plutôt
c'est la poker pathe
difficile de lire ces évolutions
à sergei est ce que quelqu'un 192 tous
fruits ce que tu fais grand direct comme
on dit sur rail à manger sur le pouce
est le même le dernier rempart du roi
peut être
peut-être bouge le fou d'en
faire sa
[Musique]
moyenne s'est
servi du coup qu'est ce que peut avoir
cette position je suis prête avait
dépensé avec les noix ou attaquer le
blog pour toute objectivité bien sûr
votre problème en termes bretonne
à mettre en
pratique c'est un très beau
ça peut provoquer ces jeux je solidifier
dernière
avec une
vente dans le même nombre ou en fait les
blanc et bleu peu plus rapide et y
attendait
les comprendre et
auquel et par la production mais
c'était batik
je crois que je touve atrides
j'imagine qu'il va nous revenir dans
quelques instants avec sa pensée et sa
connexion internet si
c'est le loader
c'est vrai que ce sacrifice t shirt 14 à
7 on voit chez un tour ça arrive souvent
notamment à surtout j'ai envie de dire
en blitz en rapide mais même en partie
classique ni des conditions si parce
qu'il ya des compensations à
radio tout cas qui réfléchit peut-être
que sont sa prépa je passe il est
exactement pareil jusqu'ici montréal est
sûr qu'il avait cette idée a donc son
dans sa besace
alors vous inquiétez pas pour les
caméras ça va revenir ce que je trouve
du poète disparu
tu du gobelet limites mais le temps de
retrouver sa connexion quelques secondes
vers revenir et bah voilà qui fit parler
du loup pour
l'ours bon pour que l'ours organes par
vidéo stouff
est allen ou le livret de tes pensées
pile à ce moment là donc on en a été
privé
de
je connais un avec un temps de 2 heures
avec
où les blancs et
l'empreinte est vraiment
là également j'ai
évidemment on a tellement il donne pas
de
noms mais vraiment prendre d'abord parce
que en pratique vraiment bien pour les
noirs plaît à tout le moins
tu d'accord mais c'est beaucoup plus
facile à le blanc sur dame betty 28 vi
le roi quand même c'est plus agréable
saluer le gâchis d'un revenu à toi
qui arrive donc au coeur de l'action
avec je pense qu'une partie on va suivre
très attentivement dans sa table famille
dié autres prague les cariatides
maintenant la question est ouverte à
tous est ce que ce qu'on fait de gros a
tout de suite
bien au maroc
à la place de jouer
la
hausse est bien que le son ne te fait
pas très beau mais je prends vraiment
recoins de haut niveau niveau réglages
nucléaire s'avèrent de sa connexion sa
connexion argentine puisque je voyage en
abs que tout est nickel
et moi
c'est l'argentine glace pas
compliqué de la connexion se poserait
pas de problème de réseau
alors à qui il n'a pas évoqué il n'a pas
joué cavalier abstrait qu'il a fait un
coup que tu avais proposé sur une autre
variante il a joué deux fois alors c'est
quoi il ya dame de foy
mais si vous jouez contre 5 il veut
mettre lui-même un crayon e5
mais
le mans 4e
je pense pas que ce soit le dessus je te
mange
pas juste les rhinites et on cherche le
mouvement dont je n'étais pas n d'abonné
du coup pourquoi m est-ce que tu as
maintenant c'est pas le fameux à chaque
partie par la pression qu'ils jouent un
coup mystère là où derrière vraiment
évident dans la position bac tout le
monde veut jouer tous les commentateurs
loach est
quel que soit le vélo à tout le monde le
ferait et lui va nous sortir un petit
peu qu'on n'a pas vu arriver
et qui n'est pas forcément la bonne
direction alors là bonjour je ne sais
pas mais
ce dernier 3
une source pions mai
koné sûr qu'on va le jouer quoi c'est un
truc on est sûrs comme un joueur que la
dame bourse est pas elle peut aller sur
cassure des 3
vallées via pourquoi pas des fois eu
deux peut-être trois bon c'est pas
exactement où
j'ai l'impression dans ces quarts à ces
balades hors parti aussi souvent vous
hésité quelques jours et de
développement notamment si vous êtes
sûrs à 100% de toute façon bas van phu
il appartient à belgrade pour cheval un
tel cas
où vous à troc de ce côté et vous
hésitez encore une autre pièce sera
peut-être mieux ici ou là h commencez
toujours par ceux dont vous êtes certain
et là j'ai l'impression que ça on peut
sincèrement
que qu'aurait dû faire pas grave bien
sûr et des lycées plus fort que nous
avoue que je dis ça vous
n'en faites vos jeux merwan rim
est ce que tu laisses les noirs se
dépêtrer reçu dit bouba comment tu des
fonds et aux fonctions déjà fait ici
d'un latine je pense qu'il a une
décision pas facile en tout cas il a
plein de possibilités et donc en
fonction de ce que karim fait là tu peux
dire bon bah qu'est ce que je fais avec
ma g batna médiator un indice
supplémentaire que va donner car avec
menaces coups
commencent par dame 3
je suis pas quelle est la nuance qui
fait que prague samuel commencer par la
meute n'entrevoit pas de
si tu veut basculer pas non je comprends
pas il veut jouer un cavalier aussi
peut-être
l'at-il besoin de pouvoir positionner
stratégiquement installé avec la vallejo
afrique je vois jouer parce que
auquel cas ça doit avoir du son c'est
effectivement
une
grosse pièce
je pense qu'il me lecavalier sinon ça
n'a pas de sens en
orbite au carat qui ne s'est pas laissé
jouer un coup logique on tombe vite
tu fais gros run j'imagine
[Musique]
et comment se construit avec les dents
section de trouver de plantes car ce que
ce que les gones sont fermés j'aimerais
bien ouvrir un peu pour mes tours
carrées qu'ils devront avoir par les
mairies facteur temps il a plus que de
foncer minutes contre une 9 15 même s'il
est très beau avec peu de temps un bon
dieu ça va pour avoir un rôle plus tard
de repartir
famille ouais
j'ai l'impression que c'est mieux on va
voir ce que nous dit le chat a fait un
effet quoi de
l'enlever le
rwanda à quoi ça va servir de
l'impression que ça un peu mieux
deuxième coup de leurs dix dames e3 ça
décale en f3 dornach
étape à choquer
mais du coup
du coup avec cavaliers c'est vrai que
alex
je peux essayer d'augmenter le son de ce
touch vous voulez pour un ca meilleur un
petit peu mais je pense que c'est la
qualité du son catalogue
je vais augmenter vous allez au diable
adam e3 est ce que cette histoire de
dans le froid mais je suis d'accord mais
forcément quand même bouger le cavalier
de peur
est ce que vous êtes même date depuis eu
deux en fait
directement puisque répondant
apparemment f7
donc voté contre 4 chez pas ça ne sont
pas si que je comprends dans les trois
hôpitaux avec des cavaliers au 5 mai
on va voir on va voir ce que je vaux
carrière et qui m
on va peut-être changer un peu parti
ceci est intéressante pour pour
l'instant en attendant son évolution
est ce que n'aurait pas revoir
marc-andré ainsi jamais
aller on connaissait c'était assez chaud
la partie est assez intéressant
de mettre encore plus fort n'hésitez pas
à me dire s'il devient trop fort trop
fort pour renault
et je voudrais
m'élever je ne gagne et maintenant plus
rarement pour marquer
donc marc andrieux une idée pour ceux
qui nous rejoignent en route qui perd
intéressant même si perso moi je t'ai
pas hyper fan au final de ce qu'il a
obtenu db sacrifier ce fou pour aller
manger ce cavalier et donc se retrouver
dans cette position
là c'était avant de forest un numéro 2
de jouer il a échangé les dames comme on
s'y attendait
et ici un stouff on est plutôt bien avec
cette paire de fois et colonne ouverte
et pas mal de jeu
j'ai l'impression qu'il n'a pas trouvé
combo mark en riant elle récupère pions
tout de suite et marquer des caraïbes
étaient deux mais c'était peut-être sur
l'aude marianne nous mener mais bien
mais ce cavalier l'un des deux
pour pouvoir tranquillement je vais j'ai
le point sur les idées la colonne jay
sur ce cavalier
ouais là je lis tout faux max
en
jeu mais cavaliers b d2 pour la
récupération de son c4
logique cavaliers français 4 mai au quai
dans storm 2 confirmant sa chambre il
est ensuite de repartir
dont g8
tiennent à liévin du coup pour pauvre et
a faim et il va demander une fois par
set et des 400 heures vous voyez cette
source est parti de rien
ok vous prend à un taux moins mais
capturer pont b1
avec la petite au final est donc sûre à
100 exposants
ici sur darwin s'en sortir
échec
ou
à 6
avec les dessous c'est de faire du rhin
points
mais
en fait à six mois l'appât du pib si
cela j'ai l'impression bon
nature des problèmes matériels
ou
ou skis si un sauvetage
vu large l'impression pris le break où
trouver des situations dans le tchat
n'hésitez pas surtout avec les nos
relations on arrive à ne pas en tête
qu'on garde le matériel qu'il ya des
compensations
j'ai du mal à trouver un truc cohérent
on résout ce problème
ce que j'affiche et des idées j'en suis
sûr un cavalier juste pour celle
soulevée s'avèrent beaucoup trop
par ailleurs j'ai juste pour montrer
comme ça
elle peut le trouver bon bien sûr ça ne
marche pas
juste ce n'est pas juste de passer de
84 par les mines attend beaucoup et oui
cette cité est restée sourde aux yeux
alors ok donc
des cas donc là
je circule et garder cette diagonale
b6 et ce à quoi tu as raison quelqu'un
que j'aime bien cette dynamique
aujourd'hui ils auront gagné c'est
reparti je vraiment pas petit bras
qui n'hésite pas à tenter
avant qu'un con tre murs d'une ville à
mettre une grosse partie est bon pour
qu'il prend en compte en ligue 1 moi qui
joue bien
donc on croise encore
beaucoup à faire
cette
croix vous prend du plomb ici ça serait
quelque chose moi je vais te manger du
garage
où beaucoup d'impact
3il petit monde en mettant fin au projet
[Musique]
des tactiques mais aujourd'hui c'est
parce que tu as mangé mais jamais vu
aussi parce que
la chaîne
avec brio
l'argovie le staff était gay en tête
1% des capacités ça y est
mais c'est du coup la
commission pour la croix à la main
c'est sûrement très bonne idée parce que
la sq avery qui va venir ont des 6 3 se
retrouve bel place et on n'aura plus
besoin d'avoir un look up on n'y arrive
pas et que les bras donc c'est très
dangereux et la bécade donc qui prend de
l'épaisseur de secours qui a peut-être
forcé
reste à capturer et l'impatience qui
soit à perdre déjà je trouve
vraiment pas
calculer pour m e bon on voit bien dans
le coup avant mais un
but d'écart
entre nous et cette séquence
il a
appuyé le bouton coupe à
l'avenir
l'endettement
et
oui mais là ça m ennuie tu bouges la
tour épreuve
ah ok aussi de
bons moments
ok donc du coup de coin de nappe à
l'académie pertes pendant an pendant les
quelque chose l'abarth après
ouais et au moins on défend
je peux pas jouer ton pays et surtout
prendre je vais y penser
ouais mais quand
on est
trop souvent
à vingt trois
points 3 sur 3
on va dire
oui mais il a pas mal
du calcul juste
du coup en fait je m'en fous et 4 me
jette pas du coup pour les blancs c'est
la question
cherche
mais les
six
sont là juste là si ces
pères de résoudre le problème
condat pattes qui divise la bad tour 17
peut-être que je peux lui jouer un
regard ailleurs intéressant juste
marquant dégâts à prendre des gars que
tu manges matour ils feront en attaque
avec deux pions la proue à croix et la
part de madame
j'aime naples fois trente premiers 1 est
en fait une taupe ou maintenant en
dépendre du trou à 3 3,8 et cammalleri
après par un
enfin plus que la
récession pour
[ __ ] aussi si
c'est faux c'est
un métier de fou le pack la même chose
pour que les parents de poindre
oui c'était plus fort sans soja tofu
ouais mais là pendant
une position chaud devant une fois
est-ce qu'il
ya beaucoup intellectuels haïtiens comme
envers nous mêmes on a galéré un petit
peu avec ses variantes aux possibilités
très tactique en voyant se trouvait
alors à comprendre a promu proposeront
au mieux au passage ouais ouais la
volt est mort de peur on allait lui fois
genre sur quoi
tomber un peu car un trois ou quatre
présidents des quatre fours b1 il faut à
3 mais par contre eu 20
ouais y'a aucune occupé après fouille de
perdre des fins qu en huilant ma défunte
défi est là pour
un regard d'avoir gardé taxe co2 au
niveau des flux ou n'importe où bah
ouais bon réflexion amère et b saint amé
l'entraînement [ __ ] à moins de vouloir
croire cavale et les
alentours on sait tous qu'il va vouloir
jouer plusieurs coups d'affilée
mais ça visuellement ça a l'air
d'aller noyer situe presque bon tu vas
que là c'était le temps mais tu as ta
pas trop mais le cas parce que tu sais
que tu peux te prendre des découvertes
de partout et on a pu
gérer
oui oui mais on n'est pas des
ordinateurs en fait et domplus ici quand
analyse cette position talent et noir tu
vois cette variante
penses tu calcules même pas te dis pas
sur toutes les découvertes je peux avec
mauroy
on a un stade se dit qu'il faut pas
rentrer là-dedans que celle que
c'était vraiment pas moi que tu es fort
c'est que c'est la seule marion jour
pour ba tu m'as tu m'attaques à jouer et
c'est
parce que tu me
l'avais dit après le royaume à pétain
laval et
3g cammalleri
est tombé
et
ouais et du coup
voilà en dés ou à hawaï mais je remonte
la vallée afin que la formule
des faits par manet ou tu veux
[Applaudissements]
mais tu regardes qu'il ya que ça de
suite tactique donc comme vous vous en
doutez hyper acrobatique puisqu'à chaque
fois c'était pour des contreportes on
attaque une pièce peut pas vraiment là
des formes de menaces et autres
chouettes adversaire par rebonds
successifs au sort des joueurs qui sont
sur un fil et si on vend dans cette
variante c'est vrai que
l'on peut être plutôt optimiste moi je
pense pour sa
part
fait leur emploi fait dgac n'a pas vu
alors ordonné à bekaert à l'hélice a
fait un bon mot je pense qu'il ya sur le
coin de réfléchir de plus d'un quart
d'heure et ça se trouve vous investir
malgré parfois mais pour accroître la
foire soit sa race après midi il vient
ne sort pas des pins il viendrait
empêcher fois coin on avait vu
alors ben en fait
porter et du coup la route pour ben
voilà bêtement 96
to b 4 sur un superbe coup de marteau de
rire
je n'ai peut-être pas tout tout tout vu
parce qu'il a autre chose mais il a dû
évidemment calculé tout c'est ma place
des élus sentir voir qui quand il est en
confiance en le jeu il a dû sentir qu'il
y avait des beaucoup de dames sur l'eau
sur le roi noir
non non
moi je crois la première victoire du
petit prodige procès aujourd'hui là ça
ça fait plaisir
le fruit est approuvée le moment prendre
la rue hier mais nul mais il en manque
un peu de recul et après dans votre
emploi remarquer parcours pour pouvoir
être même
avant d'avoir
écouté on respire souffle on va suivre
de près cette partie ça fait partie avec
quarantaine de médias prague pour trait
car yakine pour l'instant je crois que
c'est d'être ajoutés plus excitant quand
à la journée donc on va voir comment ça
évolue dans les prochaines minutes je
crois qu'ils vont les couleurs de la
piste aux jeux parce que tous les
meilleurs avant par red hat avait pas
remis d'un coup le
manager
ya les yeux j'avais pu l'appeler eu pour
noir à col roulé jusqu'au portugal et la
pépite corner ben oui il y aurait plus
de poids aux audiophiles voilà
il monte en play off ne prend pas de but
on a vu que
je trouve que dans ce tournoi il ya une
perf à plus de 2900 doute supérieure à
toutes les pertes même des joueurs du
master doctorat principal
j'espère qu'elle et son score exact je
crois qu'il est tout à fait de
l'huile et
des kamas bienvenus et bien
aujourd'hui elles sont très prometteurs
et mais moi moi je mens
avant-hier à berck est libre et en live
et moi je pensais que tu es un joueur
qui a les pieds encore en 2007 et ils
montent en flèche les îles très
important et
on pouvait le voir là on veulent que
dans le vent le matin se passe bien sur
un point elles me l'avant-centre dont
est bon c'est même beaucoup mais ils
veulent prudents quand il encore en
terre
au format le
préfet de l'oise où l'on veut que tout
le monde la nationalité indienne isro
fait j'ai l'impression que tu supportes
que tu ais je leur avais envie d'amour
cette menace j'aime beaucoup le voir
aller les joueurs montent en puissance
et
il eut enfin il ya bien peu de temps ils
étaient 2008 emplois là il adore avec
moi moi et les fruits prenez donc un
coup et lui même pas rien et puis là il
a fait toutes les terres gagnées par
tous les médias nationaux
[Musique]
du
matin
et puis les
mêmes couleurs que quelques temps mais
s'est pas foulée il est parti on est
bien d'accord savoir faciale aura
sûrement l'occasion leur prochain deux
mois justement dans master ce contrat
des meilleurs du monde serait
intéressante en attendant on va faire
une petite pause et en première table de
revenir avec la partie devant torres
juste après justement pour essayer de me
tirer au clair ce qui est en train de se
passer
mieux
[Musique]
et
non
[Musique]
vous
et
[Musique]
le
on
[Musique]
comment
bon
[Musique]
il
non
[Musique]
et nous sommes de retour vous avez raté
à bord cette petite pause les
déménagements des poufs on a entendu les
murs tremblaient les peuples trop basse
avec nokia rim petits bobos grosse
touffe tout neuf on va voir si à 107 ap
si nous sommes un petit peu mieux vous
dire je suis branché un câble à lavaur
et où vous avez promis justement il fait
froid ici aussi à flot assez claire de
revenir avec la partie de demandes pour
être contre tout bas ce qui s'était
passé à pas mal de choses et la pulsion
valérie top complexe on avait laissé les
joueurs dans une espagnole en milieu de
jeu plutôt fermé et on a quand même 10
coups qui ont été joués depuis donc donc
souvent on va voir ce qui s'est passé
par dans cette position tu nous a
expliqué il y avait des manoeuvres que
ramos était assez logique par rapport à
cette case des sacs et même parfois de
donner le fou pour pour installer une
pièce finalement ici votre masse et a
directement aux jeunes cavaliers il a
pas écoutés tour
et du boeuf irait à lutter pour cette
case en disant que c'est pas grave
déstabilisation ici parce que ce pion
vivien au centre et bien du coup
colmater les brèches très important dans
des sacs f5 et la tour peut-être pointer
dans vos recruteurs dans la colonie
des changes n'a pas été jouer cavalier
des cinq
ici h
été choisie par lula avant préventif
pour éviter tous les petits problèmes
sur la cage des sommes qui sont
récurrents
fou sekkat par une foire est sauf alors
est ce que tu peux nous expliquer ce
procès car c'était brouillon or il me le
demande le lkp veut lever 3
il me semble évident avec la tour
moi ça je pense que cette bonne raison
il ya toujours ce visage qui traînait là
où la dame était attachée à la défense
du fou ça a créé des petits points
didactique parfois la semaine du
football 5 le centre de la lande on va
voir comment ça continue
ça je suis solidaire il habite je passe
ils habitent la même mais c'est à
l'endroit juste sorti des champions
caf et au su de
tout en bas tout en maintenant la
meilleure de peinture j'ai pas aller en
board est à visiter vos chaumières mais
en fait pour vous la grandeur de
l'argent final les cantons voisins
baudelaire km au nord est l'une des
villes dont il y avait une odeur de la
remplir et aux joueurs dès l'avant tout
en voix et en fait pour faire du nord au
sud par en avion mais quatre heures
alors quand tu es bon disparue d'une
heure par exemple et
quand il fait la rencontre des quatre
heures voyez un petit peu là l'immensité
de le leur
ai juste
fait pas la brutalité du coup d'avoir
mis à part les black stars ont pas dit
que xavi ascad
moussan la nature
pouvait
saluer nice et a gâché gbagbo n'hésite
pas à poser des questions tout ça
derrière soi des questions bien sûr pour
y répondre à beaucoup de parties après
midi et long qui se passe beaucoup de
choses donc donc n'hésitez pas
je finis à l'évolution de cette partie
et ensuite ensuite on répond à la
question comme celle de p g le coût
auquel on qu'on ne la manquez pas donc
j'ai essayé de voir juste et logique
avec hp ici est une manoeuvre assez
typique dans l'espace
il va certainement pas s'en cacher car
parfois il peut aller juste apporter un
soutien aux cavaliers t5 il ya plusieurs
possibilités au g4 l'idée c'est de
reprendre avec h
parfois même attaqué alors là je sais
pas ce que sont ces possibilités des
blancs juste pour montrer on va monter
le roi réattaquer le long de la colonne
h
j'ai pas accès car
ça peut faire partie de l'idée même si
je suis pas convaincu dans cette
position je vois si c'est possible ayew
qui décèdent cahier partie kg 4 quand
même beaucoup de bailleurs
et qu'elle est revenue par trois ans
comme si vous en avez parlé comme ex
trouveront avait-il pour le fameux
contrôle on a envie d'installer cette
pièce une pièce non des 5 et notre avec
les blancs c'est de finir est une pièce
sont des 5 contre le mot mais fourcade
noir de noir mais je ne doute que du
bois
paille il rend dans ce genre d'échangés
qui lui serait défavorable
l'échangé qu'une fois a changé deux fois
mais très important pour l'instant mais
il garde - - cavaliers qui peut lutter
contre la casse des sacs
alors une prison ces trois mots qu'est
la pression est un peu l'utilisent
souvent la gaule nbc ouverte
cavaliers b6
le fonds n'a pas envie de donner les
magnifiques se fout il aurait pu choisir
de rester dans la grande galerie
d'alstom il est parti dans celle-ci
s'embêter latour protège espion voici
sous les bombes à leur barda la
déception
le jeu
normal est
tombé de sa logique d'adaptation akon
ouverte
la dame qui se décale obligé de reculer
pas dire qu'on ferme bien sûr
définitivement cette colonne à
l'étranger s'ils s'avèrent intéressants
cette manoeuvre
a joué un peu sûre
pour le roi aussi et donc le roi est
parti mon âge d aller pour éviter ce
droit
ok
bilan
ouais là mais les blancs alors de tout
arrêter a blank clairement
[Musique]
le profil qui joue pas du tout soyez
envoyés par des pions
moi je veux un peu davantage de
candidats mais trois pour empêcher avec
de nombreux effets du grand crohot pas
le doigt les gars devant qui comme les
landes
le
câble le trou est fait de mal a t il
attendre je suis ok vous
parlerons un si grand
oasis sûreté cote
parmi 1 encore appelé en trop mal et
a rallié blessé c'est l'impression qui
sert surtout pour l'instant à empêcher
ce food également de vraiment s'exprimer
en contrôlant ses cases son principal
rôle et du coup c'est quand même un rôle
plutôt passif vu aussi le rôle passif
est vrai que cette pièce joue pas et les
blue est née toujours le levier des cas
dans la position
pour prendre le sens et pour ouvrir un
peu plus les lignes et ter briller
encore davantage leur père de fou qui a
déjà des perspectives intéressantes
ouais ouais je dirais un bon avantage
blanc ici valise qui pourrait faire
combler souffre est à noter qu'après bon
remonte à coup droit des gardes bientôt
on va devoir tenir le coup mais on
pourrait même penser à un des gars là
est sûre il prit en dégâts est vent
debout loin le pion afin
de les voir
tomber pas mal de zones est aussi un
clip dans la position et le calme n'est
pas prêt de faire plein de problèmes
graphiques dans la peau sombre et la
paix pour les blancs de douai donc lamba
de l'abonné qui n'ont ni
les mêmes exploits
et justement j'étais en train de
regarder le petit doigt me dire est-ce
qu'on peut essayer de faire des 5 mai
voit ça semblait complexe effectivement
on peut peut-être le faire parce qu'il
n'ya pas ce thème
de tout reprendre cinq ici aurait pu
présenter une fourchette on sait 3 et
afu des six importants
donc des 5 et d'un coup j'ai envie de
dire parce qu'heureusement en fait pour
double parce que sinon ils auraient
peut-être été très mal et le fait
d'avoir ça retombe un peu les débats
la rigole
c'est à partir de jouer ça
écoute on va voir comment ça se passe
dans la question pourrait revenir d'alex
la ctf cacher cette question
rapport au match ou via du mont souvent
dépouillées car sa nuit était très déçu
et wasquehal reid est ton ressenti on
peut faire une petite aparté radieux
bon en fait ma part
j'avais pris qu'un but et a fait
au moins en fait n'est pointé un doigt
il a mal
une fois débarbouillé
rihanna
il n'est pas du tout l'expérience de
gagner les candidats espèrent que dans
les circonstances particulières
particulière pardon donc il n'a pas
l'expérience de ce grand rendez vous
quand même
et en fait pour moi encore que
[Musique]
tu peux rechange et comme tu étais avant
d'accepter mieux
du coup bas du bourg bruche moi moi mais
mon retour 10 a aussi été déçue pas tant
que ça tu attendais pas monts et
merveilles en fait ce match mais la
dépêche coupe du monde à part ça va
l'amour je sais pas un joueur que j'aime
bien baboo j'ai rien contre lui voilà
c'est parce qu'il pleut plus dans son
jeu j'attaque une partie par jour je
préfère présenter les candidats ça
beaucoup plus excitant comme événement à
suivre à la fois et vu que les matches
précédents déjà était pas très excitant
caruana quinssaines en qualité de jeu
c'était plus intéressant par boîte et
ouvriers tout mais quand même le déni
c'était un peu
aussi madame aubry car yakine
quincey n'était pas trop à son niveau et
cette fois c'était trop facile
enfin la première partie s'équilibrait
mais les deux joueurs veulent pas alors
il faut ensuite bas pour le taux de
dépôt s'est complètement
effondré tout c'est même pas grand chose
en fait donc
je vais pas bonne plus très convaincu
par ce masque était peut-être en termes
de qualité un des brevets auxquelles on
était dans l'histoire
tu as tout faux je veux rebondir là
dessus
les combats y est pas mal
mais de là à
pouvais tu l'avais perdu ma table et il
y en a peu qui réalisé par an
ouais je crois que c'est vraiment
difficilement audible je sais pas pour
les jours mais je sais pas si
on se met mieux c'était quand
frisbee golf
au lit tôt car
c'est la traumatiser avec la partie à
150 couderc burn out what sébacées
l'info mais cette partie-là de tuco
canal + du rire dans l'histoire de
l était pas passion à l'été attend ça
donc pour la suivante qualitativement
parlant quand même pas mal de grosses
erreurs de part et d'autre puisque ce
n'était pas évident
je sais pas on peut aussi se poser des
questions sur les types de névo sur son
entourage il a manqué un peu de
quelqu'un pour là pour le rassurer
l'auguste et
est
justement sa gestion du temps et était
aussi je pense même si l'habitabilité
avant lundi calamiteuse
cette manière de jouer toujours depuis
la salle de repos las en regardant
l'écran
se lever à chaque cours d'art de
concentration j'ai un plein de choses
qui font qu'à mon avis c'est pas les
prolongations pour se mettre au niveau
de
ce que je peux je ne sais pas si on a
retrouvé se trouve
non crise ou pas crise
nous entends stouff ouais mais là je m
en vais les emmener vers
verbaux est-ce que la
complexe
en attendant une autre question
rapport aux options options
arriérés de la retrouver dans le jazz
comment jouer contre nature mais je
pense je leur trouve que voilà
oui mais comment aller plus loin mais ça
me gêne beaucoup en partie à la faute
non c'est pas si
l'appartement par que vous êtes heureux
de la petite visite virtuelle si vous
cherchez à investir dans l'immobilier en
argentine el aziz et le moment
a priori labyrinthique et où les cafards
donc
l'assainissement eu lieu
un joli que des pions arrivée par diable
le but c'est d'éviter au maximum de
s'ancrer parce que c'est comme la son
nom l'indiqué c'est un
gamin défaut c'est quelque chose de
problématique
mois le conseil que je peux donner la
même chaque position est très spécifique
c'est dur de faire une généralité c'est
si possible ne pas s'arc-bouter en
dépenses de champion dans la passivité
tu veux juste te dire que je fais que
dépens du champion
faut essayer de trouver le moyen de ne
pas de pousser si on peut encore une
fois ça dépend des positions
on l'activé l'échangé ceinture adverse
donc à trouver des passes en 22
s'enlever ce poème des fois pas hésité
peut-être à sacrifier parfois pour
essayer de trouver un plan je sais pas
sur une autre aile pendant ce temps
trouver un avantage ailleurs quelconque
mais à
la dépense passible coûte que coûte en
fait un gymkhana elle va avoir ses
limites
voilà c'est encore une fois c'est dur de
faire des généralités comment ça peut
être un petit peu
alors qu'on appelle une rude qui nous
demandent à visiter des toilettes stouff
de faire des petits branchement
once d'or du fou
du roi sur jour des cinq ans est parti
de vannes ouest
il ya une food et de qualité joël
alors si prague gagne je monte mes
toilettes
sont alarmés les ans elle assuré c'est
prague gagne j'annonce je manquais
toilettes
après il va tout donner
vous donnez ne fait que les voies
routières
et d'autre que d'autres sens
médias
des fois 4 x 4
bah écoutes je me suis éloigné de la
boxe ça mais bon je comprends rien les
gars je pense je me branche à la boxe ça
marche pas
le wifi ils marchent nul pas mais là je
me suis mis le plus loin possible de la
boxe et ça marche je comprends vraiment
rien à speed le cinglé là bas je
n'écoute rien en fait un jeu juste
[Musique]
at il dit comme ça
c'est cool ça marche
ok
doolow qui est moins à y penser j'ai
envie de dire après la disparition de
ses pions
de fou
ok alors je pense qu'on pourrait mieux
joué que les blancs un coût qui peut
paraître un petit peu
[Musique]
anti 20 cgc 4 ouais ouais parce qu'en
cela en fait je donne ma case des quatre
mais le gars allez y les rapports des
cas
et même si jamais on arrive à échanger
mais ignorons s'il souhaite c quatre et
que tu fais un coup il ya le plan à cinq
ans lors de leur première chose et c'est
après tu fais un coup genre cavalli 17
par exemple pour essayer de
cavaliers bon là j'ai peut-être prend 17
déjà première chose mais
oui mais je perds ça mais même
tactiquement il ya peut-être du 17
mai du dans les deux et en fait je vais
même pouvoir échanger le fou contre les
cavaliers et jouer avec bonfoh en bons
fous de cases noires pour moi en tout
cas moi mr rien c'est un terreau dans
d'édification parce que moi c'était
auquel je pensais aussi aidé ou boeuf il
a joué par tenté très logique ces quatre
lui même c'est bien n'arrivera pas
qu'est ce qui fait rire ibères sont fous
qui était comment l'expliquez y perd pas
ses muscles à
plusieurs à saintes et alors j'ai passé
derrière aussi mais pourrait se créer
des avants postes intéressants pour son
cavalier oil 400 mètres très bien joué
à la fois aux droits du cou
ou rencontrer tous ces 5
mai est quand même si c'est ça quand
même on se retrouve avec un fonds
contient cavaliers font qu'il ya
beaucoup moins de 15 que tout à l'heure
donc c'est plus du tout la paire de fu
chi pour essayer de s'ouvrir dominé
l'échiquier j'ai l'impression qu'il a
résolu pas mal de ces problèmes une
série de coupes très précises adobuzz
non non ça va
la question de la question des olives de
l cacher c'était quoi déjà
on a parlé deux fois mais froid j'étais
de plus de poids
je crois que c'est la question c'est la
question à poser soit on voit bien là
parce que ça n'a jamais
rien fait je n'ai pas à cadrer
non mais en fait oui ma marge je l'avais
jamais par des dépenses avant même le
chocolat du monde et ben j'avais dit
dans mes strips d'ailleurs que je
pensais que
avant tout le moment où ou mais pour
aller faire une partie ou deux c'est
fini il y avait tout perdre d'arrière et
pour moi en fait c'est un joueur donc
excellent pour moi de da mais dans un
match
quand ils sont malmenés etc il peut très
vite en tête mais pour
une fois un peu pensé bon bien sûr à
mille fois meilleur mais bien pensé à
moi en fait
non mais c'est parce qu'en fait moi je
suis un genre qui tousse pas mal j'ai
quand je perds plus garanti d'affilée tu
peux me voir vraiment vraiment foncer
ta peau voilà tu te bouges parle aux
oiseaux et jeu
et
est en fait
dans un match où le vent changeant
meilleur que toi et que tu perds une
deux trois partis flamands d'année juste
psychologiquement c'est toi c'est pas le
joueur qui le plus fort mentalement et
est en fait tu sais pas pourquoi mais je
la pression je pensais qu'il allait mal
se passer pour lui et surtout en fait à
un moment où il perd une partie ça
allait durer avec la partie qu'il a
perdu et on est passé par toutes les
émotions
tu vois et
et je pense que psychologiquement à
pratiquer l'appareil était quand même
énorme à venir il ya eu les 8 heures de
jeu
[Musique]
c'est ça c'est ça et du coup on me l'a
jamais rigobert quoi n'a jamais réussi
et en fait ça car c'est là que je sois
motivé
c'est qu'a pris mme craxi france
sait qu'arsène qui avait perdu cette
partie exactement où plus de capacité à
rebondir il serait
battu le voit souvent malades meurent
dans des tournois camp 45e tard une
partie très souvent derrière il se fâche
clan gamme de profilés quoi on va
souvent ça ça et du coup je pense que ça
sent mauvais après c'est mon avis
peut-être
qu'avec juste reconnaissant le caractère
je pense que le match aurait été plus
intéressant s'il avait été mené
bien on a vu un même thème pour
contrecarrer keane car ça n'a été menée
et ben ammar qui l'appelle à gagner
[Musique]
ouais et
donc non c'est
[Musique]
une aile à votre taille ça je pense pas
qu'en championnat du monde c'est à dire
en prendre 40 scène la
bâtir je l'aimé ou non en parlant de
carlson
ben ali l'a eu
il a mangé à 5,1 il ya peu carrée db4 et
mamediarov a laissé manger à 5 la partie
à la vente d'avant enfin ce rapport à la
grande qu'on avait dit au tout début
juste pour les gens qui
regardent
direct qu'il a fait cavaler des 5000 à
manger bessac si jamais les noms j'ai
atteint juste avant si manger des 5 vous
prendra cinq montres et barak l'a en
fait on peut comprendre mon moi j'ai un
peu du mal à voir comment les
compensations 1 après des 4 j'ai un peu
du mal à voir une augmentation mais on
peut se dire bon il y avait quatre c4 il
ya un pion qui va être passée à la terre
de fou et c'est bon on peut essayer de
comprendre on peut se voir même si moi
je pense que c'est bien pour les pour
les blancs on peut imaginer que les
noirs un peu mieux mais dans la vente
qui n'ont eu avec apprend b5 et ben en
fait comme ils font des 5 es ben aknoun
a été ouverte c'est ça et après 71,5
après super 5 avec la même cave allé
prendre un point à 5 ou alors juste pour
les gens ici n'ont qu'un seul
et il a lancé le coordinateur à mais
s'il voulait à son tour un doute pour
atterrir ses cavales il beckham pour
s'enlever de ce thème et attaquer la
dame et vous l'occurrence 8eme généraux
finalement décidé de jouer à ce que
sacrifice de qualité pour soi pour se
marier il a dû un peu je pense à
préparer à la maison cette idée pas
forcément c'est plus exact mais cette
idée est
et donc il a dit ok ce pas je
mangeais bas tour par du coup qu'est ce
que tu ès reprendre
du concept c'est la même position
qu'avant avec la différence que la
colonne aller ouverte
après bon le fou le fou c'est 8 ben oui
les négos neil ouverte à mais le pire
des cinq est faible par rapport à tout à
l'heure où il y avait une structure avec
un point aussi ce noir le fou à 6 et
enfin le fossé ou qui est enfermé mais
avec fois a6b cats et rendra plus
ressentir le fou mais là depuis 25 ans
il est faible par rapport à la prochaine
avant de manquer quand même des
similitudes et je pense que cette cette
barre est là elle est plus rugueuse pour
les blancs que l'autre parce que
benjamin colonna et les progrès sont
aussi bons fous et - enfermé que sur
l'autre
est en fonction des quatre seuls aussi
ici est donc là nous on avait regardé
cette position
des options envisagées pour personne ce
retrait doit la défense du pion ans pour
cate a quelquefois écart s'agit là je
vais tout autre poste au final vous
voyez cette fois à 8
qu'elle n'a pas varié bien sûr bapat il
veut clouer le fou il veut changer les
tours
cette thématique
est de plus en plus ok c'est pour ça
parce que qu'ils récupèrent
quelque chose qui manquait pour des 4
as certainement une idée tactique mais
j'ai gardé après doyen le moins
de
500 jeunes oui parce que sinon pourquoi
il y aura demain x 3
faudra attendre la fin de ce mois qui
perd là malheureusement à deux reprises
de nouveau ouais mais là je prends le
train
demain demain je déménagerai
est donc là dans cette variante bouygues
récupérera un poids énorme et des
bourses active bien sûr est que
après celui ci devient faible aussi
ok du coup mamediarov
la merci de ne pas manger des cartes
bien jouer un petit peu
prophylactique ouais
ok ça pour le pari de sacrifier une
qualité est là et je vous en ai passe
passe mon tour ça vous quelques jours
utile autour du thème de magnifiques
bouquets ma vie j'ai 5
alors faites votre part vous aussi non
après telle prise de risque voilà
généralement raconte sacrifiés du
matériel on a envie de tout de suite des
raids dans l'action pour justifier quoi
[Musique]
la d'oublier tour avec pas d'autres
comme idée
assez logique même si ben on s'étonnera
colada
c'est pas si évident pour moi qu'est-ce
que qu'est ce qu'ils vont en faire
je pense qu'il ne lui ce qu il veut
juste bloqué échangés en pet quant à toi
tu as deux tôt contre une eh bien tu as
envie d'échanger à une perte de tout
repère en plus grande et plus fort oui
d'accord belle
fête une fois que j'aurais changé la
tour les tourbains j'aurai encore en
contrôle
la tour 1
à le défendre parce qu'il les cinq
bons qui se placent appui empêche fois
ci ce bon ok c'est pas
[Musique]
vrai
est-ce que cavaler b4 et cavaliers à 6
c'est une menace
mais je pense pas parce que le retour
improbable bessette je prends
je pense pas que tu puisses le faire
mais
[Musique]
à six auxquelles et manger juste une
idée
ça marche pas parce que là bas c'est
pour ça que ça m'avait l'air dans
l'esprit ok
c'est important de garder une pression
sur
lui
en
fait il faut bien jouer un coup aussi
hein c'est pas facile hein
ouais mais dans notre cas ça dépend des
cinq banques comme l'as cavel point du
cap c'est très logique
mon passage là-bas recommencèrent
beaucoup aimé les bleus
avec plus de qualité il y mettait au
début c'était à peu près équilibré mais
un équilibre passe évidence à comprendre
et à priori les derniers combats mais
n'a pas impressionné l'ordinateur
simon raymond wattiez
parce que ça c'est bon cela il va
stabiliser
peut-être pour accaparer cinq héritiers
de poche
sont aussi rentrer en finale en fait
s'il arrive à changer les dames et une
paire de tours ça va commencer à devenir
nous intéresse ouais
donc pas eu bay 4
way
you lie la gb 3 b3 ces symboles comme
beaucoup ce coût correspond ça ouais
mais en fait la menace des noirs c'était
quoi je pense c'est
b3g
way le plus le pion b2 petit faible 1 et
même on peut manger des fois en finale
plus tard avoir dû ces trois prises et b
deux équipes avancent et rapidement avec
le fou de cases blanches en russie pas
un jour en relief sans contrôle est bien
et je pense que clairement la menace des
noirs ses frères beltran et l'installer
donc du coup je pense que b3 c'est le
bon coup
et maintenant son poing
serré
la main mais il considère qu'il va
pouvoir bloquer avec lecavalier en inde
et fois la dame en d3 et c'est
donc
mais bon ce qu'il y avait à l'élément
j'ai du mal à le faire pour l'instant
avec lui qu'avec deux pions des quatre
donc faire gaffe parce que je perds
c'est vraiment le faire mais il y aura 5
mais si jamais j'arrive à perdre si je
perds 2.242 très mal très mal se passer
je regarde tout raciste a été joué donc
enlève la pression sur le pion à son
tour des quatre
et maintenant domi7 là on peut imaginer
un coup comme dam des trois ou comme ses
deux
fils et ses oeuvres de métronome
on peut imaginer aussi un cabas les
trois arrivées accablant
on s'appuie sur blaye 5 jouer être
quatre cinq parce que oui on disait
attention
je pense
pour les blancs nous rappellent
longueurs d'écart seniors sont tous les
deux seuls en tête avec cinq admis sur
vite donc si car series kyle il fait
vraiment un trou surtout si dans le même
temps neuf buts et green ne gagne pas
car ça ne prendrait un point d'avancé
pour être
apparemment guérie et gagnant et il est
vrai que là je vois la pollution et 1
[Musique]
il a béni zid alors on va peut-être
pouvoir voir ensemble quelles étaient
ses les idées parce que non s'arrêter à
ces trois jeux par des blancs
ouais non mais c'est fini comme ça s'est
coulée noire qu'on perd aussi vite là
dessus c'est fou non ouais j'ai un peu
choqués ont été là dont
il avait eu une ouverture
il a disposé de l'asymétrie mais de base
ils avaient vraiment laissé des noirs va
prendre complètement le contrôle de son
échiquier puisque c'était georges les
autres acteurs on nous disait il va pas
se passer grand chose cette partie
et design nous a donné
cette fois et puis moi je proposais je
composais hcca la place en fait sur age
3 pouvoir je fous de 600 se prendre
cavale et g5
1 mais en fait on a vu plus tard que
toute façon les noirs au moins j'ai
froid donc peut-être que sur h3 il y
aurait quand même il cavale idée de
quand même ok to 1
h 6
4 logique attaque à cinq
qui défend le cinq du coût est
maintenant du coup je vais axer ac a
valu aux trois cavaliers des soins
mais ses 6 1 qu'est
ce qui va aussi se consolidait
qui disent
je comprends pas trop non plus
l'accession de
justice
mais normalement ici c'est pas très
grave parce que souffler les blancs
barmon la richesse pour attaquer
donc là il ya eu il ya eu tous vos 3 et
là il a géré ces sept et tour f3 cavale
et des huit assez facile est-ce qu'on
n'aurait pas pu jouer à un truc comme
tour aux huit tours 7 à la place de
jouer un nom web en fait deux oui mais
en fait tu m'as jeu des cinq doigts le
tarif 3 donc moi je voudrais pouvoir
battre surtout des villes ce qui se fait
sur très froid tu veux pas défendre le
pion bref le tour
well reçoit rodez vite et voilà qu'elle
revient bien ça soit tours 8 et vers 3
oui ah oui de spss donc la voilà donc la
passe de trois et sept mois je disais
tout huit
épreuves cette toile trois tours 7 et
puis en fait je passe voiture et mes
pièces sont pas remplacés a promis de
rendre ces sept
kamel et des huit cavaliers si je sais
pas moi c'est de faire des choses
parfois
super solide
d'ici là il a balancé deux des cinq
tickets champions prend il veut jouer f5
comprendre
mais c'est un pion la reprise c'est
après il y aura toujours ces 4 1 pour
défendre le purin
c3 c6
v6
qui s'affalait mais la musique à g4 à la
suède 4 et ben même show cases blanches
de l'accotement ouvert et puis si tu
manges
tu t'es dans cet esprit
36.3 peut-être
dommage manche b5 manger des cinq super
tour à croire
mais en fait
ouais je pense qu'il a un
nom mais il était il était passif et il
n'a pas voulu souffrir plus il tient je
veux libérer mais ces décisions avaient
quand même chose à apprendre pas mais
tour victor sintes avait l'air tellement
logique à la place de voir cavaler des
huit jeux combats 3 richard pasch
théâtre
et en mélodies ressortez pièce que c'est
un homme est mort parce qu'on commande
des mecs qui ont 2007 en héros mais des
fois enfin moi ça me
rappelle c'est quand j'entraînais les
jeunes c'est georges pas
santé pièce que tu as l'impression que
c'est juste parce ans maintenant mais il
est
tout beau but de recettes c'est
tellement logique tu ramènes une pièce
en bleu
ont dit on va essayer d'ouvrir le 134e
prend des mesures radicales une fois
qu'on a placé ses pièces pour préparer à
bourrer des sacs là
comment il ya pas du tout
en fait
en fait on voit bien qu'on a quand le
roi dans b 8 et que les blanches le tour
au 3d blanc de deux tours est froid et
on voit bien que les blancs veulent
profiter de la faiblesse f7 et du coup
en fait
j'ai plusieurs manières défendre donc je
peux développer une pièce par touré
fuite non parce qu'après des passifs et
elle est passible à tous mes tours au 8e
tour 7 je suis je défends avec 7 et puis
en même temps je suis au centre donc tu
peux sortir une pièce et des formes
abstraites où tu peu mal placé une pièce
et défendrait pts 7 donc c'est un petit
peu bizarre hein tu as que la tour est
en âge fuite ma place et le cavalier
restant des huit places
et si c'est tout tu es très étonnants
d'un joueur d'un jour de ce moulin de
degas fait à part je trouve que c'est un
blocus mais il a très mal il y avait mal
évalué
ce genre de décision je la comprendrais
beaucoup plus facilement s'il était un
peu déjà dos au mur c'est une grosse
pression qua non à l'ouverture les mecs
avec les boys mais changent toutes les
pièces se trouvent dans une finale où
l'air très légèrement moins bien mais
normalement
pas de quoi s'affoler
tournoi des cadeaux
il faut un peu de réussite aux siens
caruana forfaits double of là cette
partie très certainement bien ensuite je
veux dire
non bio qui a oublié sa quatrième partie
d'affilée sapées
qu'un celle ci personne de fond que new
passé car je pense que quand sade est
plutôt bien
brian nygaard flammes
ça nous a gagné
3,7 ce qui est
à combien de temps va durer deux mois
et en plus la structure et moi je pilote
1 4 contre 59
en tout cas active et au rejet d'eau
voilà 48 heures
surprenant et au galaxy van dyck
18 coups donc c'est la partie avec grand
roque pousser un maillot d'ennemis au
collet ajoutant être conclu entre tous
d'avoir ça
allait voir sa terrestre d'ici à ce que
savait la race attractif pour les blancs
quand même pas mal ou s'est dit ok
et premier lieu le 5 tournée au québec
quelle logique contre notre le fou de
gaz
donc on avait dit qu'on avait dit flou
g5
et quelle logique parce que maintenant
pour s'enlever du cloître il faut faire
des trous sont case noire et comme
événement que vous car noir aussi 1
c'est aux lakers et
évaluer eux quatre
ils laissent quand même cadre le cap
oui oui mais en
prison des quatre hockey
intéressant cette décision du joueur ne
veut pas se prendre des 5e
et je pense qui s'est dit que en fait
les blancs et dessins carrément donné il
lui avoir à 4 5% cavailles
ce problème c'est pour ça qu'il a appris
j'ai libéré cette case après les
changements des trois
ans on voit que survolé trois
inconvénients c'est qu'on se crée un
tueur arriérés et faiblesses macheath
mais par contre on se dit est ce qu'il
n'ya pas énormément sur la chasse et la
pêche le
gardon les tons avec
le mas toujours avec une cavale il faut
carolo
comme directeur
et comme dirait kevin il veut faire
payer les changes
wedia quand il veut payer des changes
ciao maria
costa
sur le mall cop est nu
le groupe qui part
oui c'est ça que je dis stop
jean-christophe je pense qu'il veut
faire des transferts blanche à mon avis
ouais alors ça sent que c'est si ça
arrive et ça va être hyper chaud ne pas
manger en en c5 à cause du cavalier en
l'air et avec cependant plus à cause de
la tam en l'air dont il ya quand même
des problèmes tactiques
quand il a mangé en d4 tu a souligné le
fait qu'ils voulaient mettre aux
cavaliers en 1,5 après des 5 mais du
coup il a dû oublier cette idée d'avoir
ces cinq d'ailleurs
disparaissent c'est logique
aucun des joueurs mais vous les choix
chez les dames pas comme toi le royaume
tu veux garder les dames parce que le
roi lion cammas est ouvert
mais tu t'imagines pas que c'est les
blancs qui font ma télé noir en fait
ouais c'est clair
sur ses six
en pense on s'est vite
enfin j'ai bien commun de tous sans
ordinateur on s'est vraiment vous
montrer le côté humain
donc on ne triche pas salut
salut sur le temps
fou
g4s quoi moi j'ai pas ressasser ça
draine damas accuse les admet / kg si
c'est pareil
si ces dames à 50
[Musique]
musiciens composent que j'ai calé quatre
carrés au sud ce
sur quoi
j'ai triché pour voir et 7,4
richer
pour confirmer
c'est quoi l'idée parce que manger faire
d'un mach 5 après un genre faut bouger 5
l'échec à
cavaliers detroit 2-1
la vallée des trois faux prend vous
prend pour une diva malgré le froid ok
jega pour faire d'alger cinq échecs
oui j'étais raté un parent par s&p en
cours
s'assumer en fait le final quand on voit
ça à l'air hyper
hyper logique au final est donc sinon
sur les changes
positions
auxquelles vient à partit donc les 3b
vite pour essayer de ramener son four
défense après ceux
après des trous à venir si c'est pas
exactement ces 6 il n'a pas joué les six
élus directs
hockey
et l'acquis des cataractes a
l'impression que c'est un peu un petit
sac a fait
cela pour perdre d'être trop et que le
roi noir il va souffrir quand même le v6
maintenant ok ok c'est pas perdu encore
non non mais c'est désagréable mais un
comment on fait pour jouer
à long terme même en finale
espion
moi je mate et quoi
est-ce qu'une idée danon
remettre le flou et moi ce serait une
bonne idée mais bon je pourrais jamais
le faire
changer perdons ce sera mauvais chez
tech3 et je te dis en fait mal juste tu
bouges plus cavalier déjà
et away et à près d'am dam des 200 le
fou et d'être g4 chèrement d'année pour
les cages du fou
j'ai quatre cavaliers f5 est une idée
[Musique]
ont
du mal à bouger
des coûts pour les noirs
après tout aussi mettre une dame en a
quatre en tête d'un bep cap damas quatre
à six et je te dis ben vas-y on
encourage
à se remettre l'idée de matamore à 4 c
bet le front 1,6 échanger et [ __ ]
carte blanche et après fin damas y
voilà il vole mon idée
c'est moi qui volent l'asm ne sais pas
mais
après c'est un petit peu long mais bon
concrètement les noirs font quoi en fait
en plus ça mc alger qui avait les baies
5 au 6 août et vient de le montrer que
la flèche
ouais non mais j'aime beaucoup de
dollars
une vingtaine de coups donc devoir
défendre ça en étant bekkay t-notes
laissé passer plusieurs occasions
de haut niveau après ce qui est cool
aussi c'était que dans notre pari avec
avec kevin qui on a parié sur place en
finale et moi j'ai parié sur un come
back de duda
s'enfonçait
vous aurez spécial et je vais nulle
valoir mais bon
même chose
si le reposoir coeur premiers résultats
du jour là nul finalement très bonne
forest est double donc voilà il s'est
intéressé qu'à
la plus prometteuse
passé depuis et juste de bois qui a été
je pense très fascinant dans ce milieu
de joueurs pour
neutraliser l'initiative blanche et et
on voit mal aux reins statu quo et
pièces l'autre qui s'échangent le long
de la colonne des et le cavalier le fou
qui maintenant on rivalise complètement
l'un avec l'autre donc nul logique au
final et
les bonnes défenses de double vous êtes
un peu sensation
puisque tu as perdu stouff
bruits bizarres balle à moi
mais je me suis battue et quinquas par
le beau george cap a raconté je suis
rentré chez moi et j'ai alors je sors de
la salle de bains et là je vois un
cafard donc déjà atterri qui sont ils
sont énormes en argentine en
bravo pas tout le cafard il fait la
taille et mon pouce
mais au moins est même plus beau je
pense est en fait je le vois doit-on se
voit tu vois on doit mutuellement et ce
qui fait en fait le gars sait qu'il est
bien mais il venu en courant vers moi en
fait cette vidéo vous pouvez venir avec
des venus se battre et moi
du coup toujours de la chaussure ont
défoncé et est en fait il s'est mis à
côté de la porte
est fermée
et j'essaie de le taper deux fois raté
de fort et puis il a fini par se
faufiler sous la porte et elle est
d'ambon j'aurais pu ouvrir la porte de
derrière
est il bien
là bas mais c'est une porte privé qui
est parti en était avec plein de vie
donc j'aurais pu rentrer le défoncer
mais je n'ai pas trop vu du beau travail
que pour l autre jour mais comme il se
cache la peur de moi mais moi j'ai peur
de lui bon on est content et je la
comprends
oui c'est ça
du coup dans cette histoire je pense
qu'on va partir faire une pause
ou qui va s'infléchir à revenir avec
onet mort à des parties passionnantes
avec kara celle qui est peut-être sur le
point de reprendre la tête insolites et
à kerry qui va aussi peut-être qu et on
reviendra voir martin de rilhac avait
une position hyper hyper intéressante
du show juste après la pause on espère
qu'avec nous a tout de suite
[Musique]
e
et on est de retour vous êtes nombreux à
nous avoir rejoints dans le tchat il
s'est passé plein de choses et je leur a
tendu la page depuis pour abandonner et
terminer la partie stuff ouais alors on
voit un peu 45 comment se terminer non
car arsène qui qui a fait une grosse
partie un quartier qui serait partie en
son temps que parce que ils étaient
premiers ex-aequo avec ma médiocre et
une fois là bas ils amènent un peu en
avance sur le groupe enfin on avance
également abordé contre jerry
carson il il a battu rapport battu
prague nous le champion battu battu ma
médias américains ce qui tu reviens bien
un été très chaud
et donc j'essaye crise fait vraiment de
qualité qui était hyper intéressant de
la part de l'erreur bas par contre
dernier n'a pas trouvé ensuite les la
bonne façon de continuer dans son idée à
travers sa quinzaine et chirurgicales
impression way n'a pris que d excellente
décision et avec notamment cette coupe
b3 qu'on a vus ensemble et quelques
instants et la manoeuvre de cavaliers
médias roch qui a joué m6 pour essayer
de déstabiliser la position de m
pression sur l'option des cartes se
retourner très vite contre les
cavaliers du coup cassure des 3 trouve
pour aller soutenir
casef 4,6 et belle île on ressort
à rien hier que le plan des cinq ou six
bâtons de l'ariège et du coup ça va pas
tactiquement m6 a commencé déjà
difficile mais pour moi
je ne sais pas
en fait je pense qu'il est mal équipée
et qu'il faut réagir meilleur mais sont
ici c'est avec mk va laisser deux
cavaliers 3 qu'on avait évoqué avec
avec le plan des cinq qui va tomber pour
saluer car ce n 4 4 0
je pense que j'ai tout fait d'accord
dans sa tête
pas des quatre heures mais avec des
dégâts part je me battais que plusieurs
cantons j'en ai tué trois ou quatre
étapes alors je regagne à tenir
à ça je vais mieux
premier lors car c'est ni la page il a
va être utilisée
pour le cadran doha caruana carlson
encore
moins de mémoire j'ai regardé à paris
non je crois que personne il joue comme
cariat qui avec aaron avec les noirs oui
je reste plutôt solide certes nul et il
a deux deux parties avec les blocs les
rebonds et 1 passe et 2 mètres le corps
est donc pour conclure avec cette partie
et surtout reprend 1,6 il a tenté ces
deux mamediarov qu'est-ce qui se
passerait s'il voulait juste son
cavalier qui attaquait tout simplement
se trouve souvent des sacs elle s'était
terminée
il ya eu ces deux dames un abandon est
sûre cavaliers detroit est ce qu'on
faisait ici
à bien un client il ya tout procède par
langogne mende moi j'avais pensé ça
prend des 5 avec le joli concept échec
mais en fait nous faisons un
tour de plus le pion ces deux répond
baisse s'est complètement saga une pièce
dans une position
d'où l'abandon on s'attendait pas à ce
que ça se termine celui là iront 27
pouces seulement qu'un seul au début de
la partie pour ce qui était pâle avec
nous il y avait une idée je remonte très
vite très intéressant pas forcément très
connue de ma vie dira
khalef certes manoeuvre de tours
l'hôtesse est grande diagonale et
permettra défense de son autorité
derrière ça
impressionnant
et
je pensais tout à fait du goût qui doit
pas aller à à partir parce que fawcett
en fait il a permis ce sacrifice voir
voilà
impressionnant du champion du monde donc
qui prend seul la tête du tournoi avec
six et demi sur
sur combien nature 9
ouais et donnons donc algérie qui a
aussi fini pendant la pause parler
directement avec nous on avait vu à une
ouverture tout très plate s'attendait
pas grand chose dans cette partie avec
de l'asymétrie des choses la dame comme
d'analyser ensemble un champion
s'est complètement écroulé
fait des choix bizarres une position
derrière solide par ici
l'envoyé des pions
cette finale on était là je crois j'ai
deux c'est toujours en vie c'est la fin
de la partie puisque c'était son exploit
sans espoir
et on va regarder la france envoie un
plumeau soufflé une baie 3 5
il
semblait
ropion
s'échangent
et tour ses six jolies petites pointes
final
si la tour bouge bien gp prend ses
quatre j'ai trop de poils qui va tomber
aussi à l'adoption passé
et mon bateau ben je comprends et je
veux pas défendre les deux
je pense oui car très important donc le
pion ca pas à pas le temps de passer
comme quoi on a trois qui me passait
donc une victoire cette fois-ci techlid
en règle et rila il a compris facilement
pourquoi ouais c'est facile mais je
pense tout autre wac avait croisé cette
photo
en fait je crois que la plus grosse
moitié des 5 mais juste sur 800
m en simple
incompréhensible alors je sais que tu as
envie d'aller voir petit rail mais je
propose quoi ouais on commence par faire
un saut chez mario morisi on a vu nous
qu'on ne va plus il était peut-être sur
le point de remporter sa première partie
parti c'est ça qui était passionné par
les petits spahis le prague et s'est un
peu effondré et on va en grâce à ça
s'arrête
donc on était à 8 heures et bertoua
salut à toi
et dj mag de jeter encore charcuterie
coûte d'ailleurs ils disaient qu'ils
étaient plus le penalty sur grenoble on
les ya quand même de 1710 l'eau bah
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la marque jouer le ça arrive
mais tout d'abord sincèrement
qu'on va devoir modérer pas tous aussi
à la pression les payas se permet le
sqbb cadre d'analysé en velours c'était
hyper intéressant
venir vite il y avait cette idée et on a
vu que c'était très dangereux pour la
noire même s'ils avaient des pirouettes
pour essaie de s'en sortir c'était très
dangereux
et il y avait cette idée aussi surtout
s'il faut reculer le fou plan carrière
aura 3 et les gros problèmes
sur le roi droit de s'asseoir et donc il
a joint un couperet pas prévu à 20 mo
est elle fout des sacs contre attaque
sur le guerrier donc sa valeur est
plutôt malin de sa part
mais de petits cartons jaunes du coup sa
marque en rien à manger le saut il s'est
dit je veux jouer sur les cases noires
ok semblait pas si claire du coup
robert gober cette je pense à couper ça
c'est la partie ouest des six empêche
cavaliers 6 parce qu'il y aurait deux
tours combes et 5 et ont pensé ce 6 mai
sionards regardez moi ça a croisé par
stouff atteint
moi peur on ne cède pas de l'ordinateur
etc est jusqu'ici
dr t6 du coup tour ces épithètes est
joué s'énerve anesthésistes attaque le
pion trois logiques
et là cavalier si si c'est possible
grâce à la barre tout
juste sur les gaz blanche paraît logique
de reposer ici bah oui si on doit alors
ok
mais il a dû réussir à ramener son
cavalier à l'attaquant marc andré
leroy qui
cavale et imad
en jeu qu'à probablement parce que je
vois pas y'a pas de pacte la
canadia 5 était joué
nadeau de quatre pièces qui sont dans le
besoin d'un peu de mal
à les activer ou à les coordonnés
correctement
et tour h4 peut-être l'idée d'aller
manger les pions
basque
en plus ça empêche aussi kbc 4 c'est
vraiment très bien joué je pense que
c'est le moment il prend l'avantagé en
partant de rien sur ce coup a été raté
par son adversaire tu va libérer cette
cadence gros son cavalier est donc super
beaucoup
pourtant ces cinq
qui mange le pion qui est lourdement
sacrifier mais a priori ça va créer des
d'été riment de match il n'a pas peur et
a maintenant le joueur néerlandais là
parce qu'il n'ya pas de mettre du
couloir contrôle où les mêmes sera bref
un contrôle hogan plein de choses
et tout rejet carte était joué j'attaque
la suite la whey je me laisse une
enfilade donc s'adresse que le gagnant
donc que votre forest ou via logiquement
projet 5 stib assez bon résumé de
problèmes dans je te bloque et je m'en
vais
et sur h4
c'est la barre ci est ce qu'on peut pour
g6
parce que là il a mangé
[Musique]
et si jamais fait de revenir ouais mais
là je peux manger kg 4
grammes est possible aussi manger j'ai
fait le plus rage suis avancé le pion un
pion à acheter il était blanc
ok on va les prendre les quatre points
qu'il a plus que lui qu'une minute aussi
un vin de fraises donc il est sur le
point de tomber donc là on menace
si ce qu'il penserait le roi noir
allaient dans une diagonale
on l'attend de pied ferme et vous prie
une découverte
qui a ignoré toutes la boutique et ses
filles a pas de cours puisqu'elle vient
au passage assez pour tout à jouer ces
deux matches il s'est fait math ayant
quelques spoilers et est magnifique
matray en double victoire est-ce que
c'était parable sais pas je vais tour
s'est vite tente de chercher
la gagne il ya eu autour d un tour d un
jeu par jeu par rien du tout je visible
même au delà cette cabane à 9,6 et le
crois que ça m'a pas par am et à ses
magnifiques comment tu pars le matin
est imparable de meilleurs coûts ses
tours ses cinq
faut prendre bien sûr
de la partie elle a joué au fc où il a
lu matin certainement la bulle match
mais s'est dit ok bah bravo ses cheveux
ses rabais de sa part d'ailleurs
superbe super victoire de braquo driassa
lui faire beaucoup de bien au club ouais
aux geôliers
il montre son talent dans cette partie
il a pu revoir en fait il l'a plus lâché
ses coups il a fait plein de très beaux
bk trafic au tour b4 l'impression qu'il
a joué libéré cette partie
mais il a pris la france avec avec la
belle partie d'hier déjà est au bord du
quai blanc il a l'argent dessus joe son
jeu quoi donc on espère que pour la
flûte tournoi ça va ça va
s'il sourire donc là juste pour vous
dire demain et compte qui va jouer
demain il y aura les noirs contre max
farmer dame
de masi 116e
minute
c'est un des préparateurs de grille
après laurent blanc contre daniel garda
dont qui est belge
a pris le relais noir contre eux
reuven vos gueules
voilà le genre qui est à dreux et lui
sont comme lui et il aura les blancs
dernière partie contre les gasy aux
antilles peut le stopper
ouais y'a moyen de faire des petits
points 15
28-26 surf sur cette vague si je joue à
ce niveau il c'est sûr qu'avoir il a
marqué deux fois et va gagner deux
parties
du coup est ce que vous trouvez dans une
jatte comment comme en retard nous
risquons un moyen même si on perd pas
partie quelque chose
salut c'est baptiste 27
alors retour s'est engraissé 35 ça
paraît beaucoup
sur une face on trouve deux pas se faire
à présent que le plus haut je n'ai pas
l'impression que le haut mais je pense
que le plus plus long que c'est fou des
trois
tours contours c'est un court terme est
d'abord un trou et le remettre le font
trop
soit donc ces 5
oui mais bon vu que mes valeurs
et je
souhaitais dédier une pièce juste
[Musique]
ok bon c'est perdu on va peut-être aller
sur une partie plus sérieuse
je sais que c'est cela oui la faiblesse
des cadeaux à rien de concret sur la
zone bat pablo un finish quand même on
voit pas de plus joueur nettement
la belle je mettrais ouais je maîtrise
du pouvoir tourner au tournoi principal
pour vous le rappeler car hassan qui rit
qui viennent de gagner non qui sont en
tête et qu'un seul point d'avancé je te
propose ce fait très longtemps qu'on
n'est pas les voir avec le voir chaque
toit
en bout d'impatience
oui tu as un herbivore et je comprends
cette position de témoin entre
paris et a amené son sol
peut-on prendre 5 gt gt s'est
enthousiasmé les critiques in
est dur à passer quand même il s'est
passé quoi et je n'ai pas écrit ce
matin
donc on souhaitait à adam 3 je crois
mais ces femmes ou là pour ceux qui nous
rejoint il encore on venait d'assister
ça a l'air hyper chaud brac avait envoyé
sacrifier la tour ce rachat
clay blanc vous attendez au gros rock
une tour carrée aux achats et une grosse
attaque cardiaque et a joué scoop d'art
deux fois que j'avais un petit peu
surpris
trois pattes avec la garde des sceaux
s'est arrêté il a joué à quatre du gros
rock maintenant
le 6
tours achats au gaïac à la logique
invité en fait assez peut-être pas
coincé dit je vais me barek mauroy et je
vais te contre attaque la sueur
là dessus mais c'est vrai que j'ai eu
mal toujours avoir une utilité pour
assange à terme 3 du coût de
2 prague
perdu un peu de temps
vous n'avez qu'à évoquer
justifie
parce que j'ai quand même très fort
d'un mobile 7
la ligue est 3 doigts si la dame était
resté en d2 et prix twh 1 % qu'on
n'aurait pas eu besoin de venir défendre
les deux
mois j'ai parlé de la meute points
revenir et moi j'aime bien ce qu'a
d'ailleurs
2,7 en france tu vas jouer qualité trois
matches de suite tu vois tu es le plus
chaud que 10 à toi qu'est-ce que tu es
que noir ce que si le nom est jouée à
trois on va fermer très heureux y aura
plus d attaques sur le roi elle en
valait pas des cessions
je pense que david est plus précis ici
et je veux qu'il y ait des trois tout de
suite
si je pense qu'il va les mettre sa dame
aura quatre
mais on va en fait que qui l'a jamais
vraiment une patate d'attaqué en patins
jamais comment le temps de l'attaqué le
roi noir
préparatoire au défensif
d'améliorer la côte
basque aurait dû aller plus vite son
attaquant pourquoi h cinq ans mais les
pièces et il a joué dans mes trois
cavaliers croix gammée le 5 février toi
c'est un petit peu lent tout ce qui fait
donc moi j'attends demain qu'il faut
défendre le plan c 5 tout ça mais
mais je ne sais pas j'ai l'impression
que c'est roland quoi ces artificiers
maintenant près d'am c4 et ben je
reprends des quatre
éléphants ajouté ouais bon jeu comme un
pion un pion dossier ce qui peut être un
peu faible mais bon comment ça pue un
peu
surjouée
la tombe et la f6 très bienvenu qui
empêche camaïeu 5 1 et est-ce qu'on peut
essayer de jouer une idée d'employés roi
ces deux genres tour b3 il a fait j'ai 4
e un coup comme cadel et b4 ces sujets
ou pas
belle idée d'essayer d'aller
d'aller taquiner le plan c 6 à winneba
et est-ce que tu aimais 4 avant tomber 3
c'est possible
assure la gestion mais j'ai reçu tout le
temps j'aurais tour ses 4 rebonds de
troy mais j'ai pas pris un
savon 3 peut-être qu'au bon moment
et b4 suite ben un petit peu avant un
petit peu avant de tomber 3 pour essayer
d'empêcher les dès demain je pense parce
que ça si j'arrive à te mettre une tour
en genre une tour ans et beat là tu vas
être forcée en fait d'être passif un
petit peu
absente
c'était
ok go crise prises et si ça
marche et par un choc déjà
le cas du mari 36 je trouvais les idées
mais
non mais c'était trop peu
quand tu prends h5 clairement le
dispatch pneumatiques et ça s'est mal
passé il est un peu lent dans tout çà
et là mais non imposition à l'ailé
elle est presque désespérée pour
reste c'est un peu pour ça c'était pas
l'un des bras pour matériel mais c'est
une position où il avait un peu c'est
pouvoir tourner accroître son avantage
petit à petit et techniquement il a été
impérial et là il ya
après ma loge à la pression donc
je ne t'aime pas de faux cher de la peau
de pas si facile de progresser un statu
quo ce cavalier quand même fort hills
est un bon coup de gaz
et la canadienne va devoir trouver
un moyen de percer
voirie long voyage
il n'a pas trouvé chose que que de jeu
sa suite parce qu'en fait d'avoir une
position
et du coup il a décidé de jeu à chaque
soir puis on prend inscriront jours à
être sacré or je pense
lié sait le faire toi je suis tu manges
et le plonge avec la toile et défendre
si sûr tout dépend de si ça parce que
si
on peut prendre
mais j'ai 55 ans
mais j'ai quand même tour à six
amis roi iron iii iv le roi ait trois ou
quatre on prend des quatre aux irois f3
peut-être un jour manger occupions gt3
manger avec deux banques et ça ça a pas
le droit est trop hâtif donc le prétexte
car il a délogé
donc été très intéressante
c'est quoi le coriace 13 minutes à
prague sa carrière qui n'a cette quoi
jouer h5
égouts sinon il peut c'est de rentrer là
dedans et banquette ont droit passe pas
bon c'est pas fini il ya quand même du
les bourses aux choses il ya des pions
d'un cavalier qui siki moufles et drôle
mais je pense qu'il va s'offrir
d'être peut-être ici je veux qu'à mais
les blés 4 mais sans conviction
parce
qu'elles supportent juste de cavale et
mes gars tu là
ouais parce qu'en fait
ceci sans l'air et puis tu peux pas trop
trop j'avais
donc je fais roi des deux
ainsi ce que après je sais pas
est ce que je peux faire cavaler
processus avant de croire ce que t'as
qu'à tours
m34
ben je tacle à tour
village est costaud
moi j'avais plongé
aussi peut-être tout cas valu sept alors
peut-être plus malin
ouais et pourtant le bienfait de la
ligue et manger
à partir c'est
bon
c'est pas encore fini mais il faut les
trouver le coup 1
ces sources s'est aussi trouvée
il reste cette coiffe à faire les deux
donc cinq minutes pour karekin 10 pour
prague i7 coup avant d'arriver au 40e et
d'avoir l'un crémant de 50 minutes alors
tu vois que tu es allé voir caruana je
crois que les gens réclament
le bon chemin de nils est grande et luce
à l'image
ils sont occupés gamme coup ils ont à
grande et lorsqu'il ya quinze secondes
oui pour jouer neuf où
je rappelle à chaque fois il ya trente
secondes par coup à temps d'assister ne
va pas tomber en direct alors assez vite
du coup pour retourner à l'action on
était sur une française et oui
effectivement comme si on faisait avec
sa carla qui joue un peu tout dans ce
tournoi il a joué notamment avec les
blancs avaient contre thierry un double
pyong et au final pas mal l'ouverture
change un petit peu ce répertoire je
pense qu'il veut brouiller les pistes
avant les candidats à ne pas sortir ses
traits pas aussi pour les candidats
certainement une des raisons principales
est toujours plein de choses sinon il
peut mettre un peu le doute à ses
adversaires futur pour l'échéance qu'il
a plus important de poule et
donc ont été par ici avec le plan de
route avait parlé de tout ce qui était
mal sic d'envoyer g34 pour aller
attaquer le roy on a toutes les pièces
braga moi c'est le genre de position
c'est vrai que j'aime bien avec les
blancs
côté droit on va essayer de réagir par
ici
donc celui de cavaliers enfin que
maillage de thématiques 1 les cavaliers
gcard compliqués sont les noix et
regroupent leurs pièces pas réussir et
les blancs ont regroupé leurs pièces par
là bas donc c'est très les intentions
les deux joueurs sont très claires
pascal magnier c'est un super défenseur
souffre du roi
et gk donc là on introduit maintenant
des thèmes de sacrifices à faire très
très attention
sauf que tu as peur d'un cafard stouff
non dans sa vie un petit bruit un petit
je vais te piquer
non juste gens il y avait une ambiance
qui passait donc vu le public ou
alors françois pour les candidats maxime
c'est lé grand prix 1 qui va disputer
ses panneaux
pnc les grands prix ça va commencer
tellement à trier
mieux ça va être compliqué à trois
grands prix chaque voir participera à
deux des trois grands prix
le format assez particulier ils vont
faire des groupes de quatre joueurs
et
c'est seulement le premier de chaque
groupe se qualifient pour les demi
finales et finales et on marque des
points en fonction de base si on gagne
le grand prix si on fait finaliste si on
fait demi finalistes qui ont fait 2e de
son groupe troisième de son veau et il
faut avoir le plus de points à la fin
des des trois grands prix les deux
premiers et deux joueurs qui marque plus
de points se qualifieront mais aura du
beau monde 1 0
normalement pas que sow il est qualifié
mais je crois pas s'il va jouer
le système est très particulier d'un
avantage d'ailleurs de jouer les
derniers grands prix parce que patrice
evra ce qu'ont fait les autres c'est
très bizarre on aura honoré cette scène
bacrot qui sera là
étienne marcoux ils jouent les deux
premiers je crois et maxime semble
qu'ils jouent les deux derniers
si je dis pas de bêtise ça se déroulera
en a deux qui sont en allemagne
c'est un psy je crois et les infos sur
chaise comme berne article avec un petit
peu récap vous de pouvoir trouver ça ça
vous intéresse de voir le détail un peu
les joueurs les participant es les dates
précises
mois pour une parenthèse grand prix
candidat
chaque chose qu'un mandat puisque car on
a mis un peu de temps réfléchisse ouf
alors ici mais l'option à trois essais
clairement ouais super fois qu'on
assiste un sélective on aurait un jour
on dames les deux c'est bien normal de
la paroisse n'a atteint 4 reposer changé
d'âme bonne position où les blancs
peuvent sacrifier à chaque coup eh ben
il est important de protéger d'un
de ses traders
et oui on va signer avec ces personnes
après moi je
je crois pas trop à la cadence format
mais bon après si ya beaucoup de nuls et
à chaque fois il ya les départage sont
rapides mais je suis assez sceptique
quant aux chances de dacca à part si
vraiment il bosse très parcours d'un
kader qui était un qualifié il était
habité par
la filiale invités de la file un invité
des organisateurs
chez plus qui est qui me les a invités
n'a qu'à
d'autres je crois que c'est du bois fin
mai à cet agent le plus dangereux après
bien sûr il est capable
donc
compté jusqu à garder les dames
logique
il enlève son roi par rapport aux prix
sur échec j'imagine ce toujours
un peu peur avec les nôtres ici je serai
passera mais faut croire si l'on prend
et madame royal ou g5 mais bon il ya des
trucs faut faire attention un trou il ya
des ponts des quatre 4 jours en prison
ces petits problèmes là c'est pour ça
que c'est pas si facile de sacrifier
nom d'ahmed
3,8
et thématiques mais à ok c'est très
chaud au cnas cavale et prend 1,8 et
d'un point à 9,7 quand même
il ya eu cavale et prend des cadres
imagine
toi il ya foule proches c'est ce qui
arrive il faut que j'essaie de faire
très mal
ce que dame g4 doit être le plus fort
or ce matc un arabe
et j'ai dit non non je la récupère la
pièce et c'est bien sûr terminée on va
mater ce cavalier m6 était imprenable
et évidemment car audrey pas tomber dans
ce piège il a mangé des quatre
pieds dans le rouge les garde fous rires
il veut c'est une cave chaud en cette
position à
blaye clairement les trois résultats
sont possibles aussi
cavalli qui essaient de revenir à ça
quand même quitte à perdre un pion mais
au moins pour la change s'échanger
contre nate accordé blanc
essaie de te défendre
clavier prend évite
8 ou prendra donc les paroles de change
devraient largement soulager les noirs
au moins en termes de perspectives d'
attaque sans quoi pu se faire mater a
priori
évoquions d'équipage et il aspire à 3 au
6 1
j'ai l'impression que ça tourne plutôt
bien en faveur de caruana les
complications stuff
six cartels naturel on se place
ouais un peu de jouer encore trois
pièces
ok ils du coup il simplifie
détroit
qui commence à devenir d'autres
commentaires at on va les manger à 3 3
c'est la partie
il ya eu les six
complètement perdants dans ce cas fait
tordre
image s'est pas
prise prise 3 euros
j'ai plein d'amis le mans
demain à nos hommes ont bon moral dans
la tête et pas de coin des six n'ont
jamais vu prendre pu reprendre un
serpent des huit ans
je n'ai pas vu j'ai pas vu
[Musique]
il peut y avoir des modeuses des
flamands
donc la
rd23 wells des deux tours d'inde
annonce de l'étude ils peuvent
évidemment
pas de là puisque un jeu permet de la
motion
à temps de calcul un peu mais
normalement ici ça sent qu'il doit
gagner pour les noirs mais ajuste un ton
passé d' avance
savoir impression obtient son permis de
place
est ce que dame ces deux menaces pas des
deux
échecs 1
et pour des huit
attaques pompiers agathois de huit jours
on va vite le savoir puisque c'est passé
c'est le coin ce
qu'on voit pas très bien quel est le
gain trouvait pas à la question à trois
et à voir sa volonté d'avoir des sept
qui crée beaucoup trop tonnes pour
montrer que c'est beaucoup trop long à 3
attention quand même à prandelli s'il a
aussi décidé la banque avance également
nous faut certainement s'occuper de ses
pions alors il est où le gaz tout filet
où
il est où
[Musique]
je regarde
tout cela je regarde des albères ça
c'était du souffle et peut-être faut
juste ça a mené la dame en défense au
piège
ça se sache pas si vous allez
même si je suis à 3 maintenant et que tu
joues 17 saddam b5 attaque le pion à
table pro b 8 lui de ce truc
faisait mener 5-1 mais qu un peu triste
de reculer comme
d'appoint à la plaza 3
mais bon c'est un peu triste de devoir
écrire
des
pandémies du coup
et prague il est rentré dans la bande
qu'on l'avait dit avec cavaler procès 6
1 ok
tu proposes de rester amis site ce qui
reste oui oui le match que je spoile
intéresse vraiment que quelques minutes
aux deux joueurs c'est un coût pour
atteindre isaac note on a envie de
comprendre qu'avant la décision
est-ce que tout aille
mais peut-être pas de flash chistopher
ondam v5 c'est peut-être juste juste à
suffire en dépendent en autres deux
pions et on contrôle le pion adverse
et qu'on a on a envie de calculer
quelque chose de plus concret mais
finalement c'est peut-être le mieux pour
fabien
saby qui a enchaîné une deuxième
victoire d'affilée avec les noirs qui
plus est deux victoires de suite avec
les north il se relancerait complètement
mon ce tournoi même si elle sera assez
loin de 40 cède pour moi sur le plan
personnel il avait très très clément
avec les doigts avant le jour de repos
est alors il a joué un coup de dames il
a choisi la casse cette fois
d'accord voilà va regarder la barre des
novations la jauge qui indique que la
partie revenue à égalité
dans ces 3 si la barre à ne dit pas
n'importe quoi c'est bon c'est une
grosse c'est rare
ça ne gagne pas après van diffuse
pour ça il ya que quelques secondes pour
trouver et donc le bon coin ce taux
s'était bien tomber sa carrière et
peut-être d'autres
rôles
est ce que ton chien je préfère des deux
amédée de garde est retourné un tour et
les tourbains étourdir la tempête on
veut provoquer des deux pour aller
manger ce pion c'est peut-être ça qui
l'a raté
faby et tour salaire de sauver peut-être
le seul vrai grand déluge qui avait
juste celle à nul autre qu'un celle
ci je voudrais d'ailleurs pirate bay 7
avec d'un premier but est en tord c'est
lui bon ok tu peux pas trop
pourquoi je me donne cette fois ci
il n'a pas vu village de tondeurs direct
autour de sap r c'est raté par
raté par telus caruana c'est pas fini on
peut encore se passer
caruana a rendu compte qu'ils
lutteraient chose que ces tours servent
et on gagne un temps sur la table les
blés noirs viennent de bouger leurs
dames et finalement se fait attaquer et
d2 comme vient de le boire marche pas
parce qu'on va jusqu'à nier les pions
donc cela d'amour bouger je sais pas
aujourd'hui
c'était man u 17 donc
madame à
5,25
et pas compte des huit mais bon certains
leur niveau ou d'un peu de te perdre ta
connection mon cher sauf malheureusement
on espère que ça va pas durer
si on bouge à la peau
noire et métissée juste on a perdu un
temps pour rien
donc donc à priori
oui le t2t forcé ici du coup si on perd
ce pion bas ça va être dur raconte
chaque côté ensuite
et
double double gaffe
garde mutuel des deux joueurs c'est pas
facile hein la position assez complexe
et il ya très peu de temps la pendule
c'était malgré tout trouve à bord
nettement je pense à cette idée
je te régule
des couples bijoux quoi pour les bons
coups bas les pèlerins quel génie
on va vite aller voir ça dès que c'est à
notre
stack et villa trop plat et doit être
tous fous je crois que chara qui a
exposé est acceptée sur internet
tellement fou
et donc je retourne à eltham ces deux et
ça maintenant et ici non de la tête il
donne de l'hymne grandi lui s il a
compris je pense qu'il vient de se
rendre compte qu'ils avaient raté
peut-être tour c'est un
terrible pour le joueur suédois
c'est bien dommage ou d'amd de à la
bombe est d'une extrême nice à 3
secondes mais cette finale a sept frères
et va être perdante
quelques gagnon se trouve d'après toi
ici
on verra ça m'a l'air va
ça va faire mal
bien après midi alain personnellement
secteu man
pâtit ce n'est
pas notre option est en fait c'est
richie ton pseudo faut savoir c'est
tremblay
badia sa 7e chain et oui c'est le
lumineux cannes bravo par omtv très bien
joué pour bien au chaud sur le thème du
cloud h sur la première rangée
et lorsque rigolo séjourner sur d'un pro
d2 du coup 0 et nadal et la maintenance
et des blonds qui gagnent parce que joe
inarrêtable
je jouais là-bas ça pour l'arrêter une
première fois mais un échec
ouf et dames et a pas de perpétuels donc
l'attention au piège
ici c'est bien la tour qu'il faut manger
sur l'échec
attendait les jours non pas de sa seule
chose de revenir au direct
il n'y a pas eu il ya eu tomber un
parent par paroisse la face et surpris
leur tête que a trois grilles aussi un
salaire salaire fois parce que c'est
vrai que le pion 17 qui a été poussée
est sous contrôle
de dakar du bicentenaire est marrant que
seront ses deux filles on prend ces deux
et huit dames tour en lui l'échec 3 h 16
et bien qu'il ne pourra pas le pion
d'al-adha trop vite robot stouff
sac tu nous disais à la salle bizet et
oui cette option on peut pas les arrêter
de tous les deux à la tour elle ne peut
pas se couper en deux et vu quelque part
de revenir sur la première rangée bas
à 2 tours noir est promu et donc la
victoire des pions on peut la poule
c'est joli
et je pense qu'on va assister
il va atteindre le 40e coup un mail à la
brosse ronde devrait pas tarder
et des grottes et lieux se balancent en
arrière vois c'est qu'on sent qu'il a
raté ici malheureusement pour lui
comment on finit stouff
entamant et dimanche il menacé des dames
8 par exemple des chèques
alors le multi militante
temps d'user
des deux proposés par souffre pas d'un
mais de
deux galileo
6h 3h en double dames 2 c'est l'avis des
cantons but m'a gagné grâce à grâce à
système de la torah puissante contre les
deux ça ça se vend beaucoup stouff de se
moquer de la tour blanche
est les suédois qui
souffrent ce
jeu contre rythmes endiablés c'est dur
pour lui et l'a
alors sur des deux
l'idée c'est que sur tour pro d2 tout
fait
juste sûr
étalée
sur deux
ans
car madame deux airois c2 est
plus élevé parce que c'est son 40e mais
je pense qu'on y viendra se rasseoir
csap loi pour abandonner malheureusement
pour lui du coup souffre on va basculer
ou attendent le dernier coup de 40 a
quand même le 40e coup de carnoët lui à
50 secondes et basculera sur ton petit
protégé
qui est donc en train de faire des
siennes apparemment germaneau création
la whey à part ça je viens pas te le dis
le 39e bon match et j'avais l'ordinateur
je regardais un pur proie c'est le
secret difficile et il peut pas
davantage au québec
et il a pas trouvé quoi
ou sur caruana faut pas oublier la
pendule c'est le 40e de cette bête de
tomber ici
je rends bien qui nous a déjà fait une
merveille au 40e coup et les ou au roi
chez
voilà
il ya plus de cheveux pour 2008 il
s'enlève la première rangée qui est
toujours dangereuse
et il garde ses menaces à l'exception
donc ok on va on va basculer sur un
contre carradine s'est passé plein de
choses comme tout vous l'a annoncé vous
suivre aussi un peu de votre côté
parallèlement il visait d'atteindre le
40e les deux joueurs de pouvoir vivre
tranquillement le deuil d'un ensemble
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
cette répétition good ont évité par
karine steve qu'envoyer h&m pour essayer
de gagner à tout prix
qu'on poulenc ou ce qu'on avait pensé et
leroy qui vient défendre ici le pion et
ont aidé donc un très bonne idée a
priori cavaliers bekkat pour forcer les
événements et essayer d'aller manger des
saucisses
c'est la partie assez exactement ce
qu'on regarde
il a mangé ses 6 ok on sait que ça peut
être dangereux pour les noirs
et là apparemment elle tout le monde
attend c'est donc qu'ils appellent pour
couvrir tous partis rocher vite nous qui
nous semblait plus belle c'est le
voir ce qu'il faut les récupérer
cet ouvrage fait mais bon ils jouent
pour le gardon qu est ce qu il a calculé
mon tour c'est vide
car il ya sept
donc l'idée à saran d'escorté scipion un
dab
pour un mythe
kébé 5
attention fourchette contrôler la case
de promotion après
roy prend trois
sépales beaucoup des ponts se trouve du
coup kerry bessac si je crois que oui
il mais abaisse tu vas prendre 3 et 1
ramené 2 h 6
6 qui fâchent h6 bonté c'est très dur de
kilomètres le pion à la tête et après
l'édition et coutu lancé
cette droite me revient alors à tempérer
pourquoi as tu as mangé cinq parties
mais je sais pas je le sais même pas
si je prends
tu n'arrêtes pas la géographie et 6 et 7
ok ce que j'attendais
je vais mettre l'ordinateur va nous
aider nous aussi c'est la quatrième
heure de jeu commence à fatiguer
batterie chant même si un pépin de l'or
puisque là c'est vraiment dur bienvenus
ouais c'est notre cher par nous-mêmes
mais j'étais un petit elle aussi avec
des choix de ces deux variantes hyper
complexe
et la répression dans lequel la route
xrs et du calcul brute pur
donc tour s'est vite
à 1,5 était jeune
on était là
on est en train de regarder
usé que si sa priorité le bon coup on
n'était pas très bon vidic et c7 donc
chez moi
mais là lui qui change pas mal changé du
coup oui indiqué laisser croire
ses ciseaux mythix est perdant
6 plus fort
pour ces huit
îles des six attaques la tour
tour c'est ça plutôt nul non alors tu
fais une espèce de perpète
chantage sur la
g de comprendre ce qui se passe dans la
partie déjà
sait si c'est pourquoi c'est si c'est
mauvais a priori course élite
je ne comprends rien même l'ordinateur
vis ma vie a un coût je vais l'enlever
les coûts parce qu'il écoute beaucoup il
dit plus froid sur un coût que penser
quand je joue le coup il passe à
l'évaluation inverse donc écoute on
essaie de dévaluer par nous même
nous aider dans le château ci sera grand
plaisir position qui est hyper compliqué
on va essayer de comprendre ensemble à
prendre notre temps
il a joué eu cinq en plus ici gaillac et
niveleuses créer un pion passer
ça c'est sûr que c'est son idée soit le
pion f sont inclinés ils sont tous deux
perdent des pions ce qui compte ce qui
en est un et qu'il arrive ce pourra à
l'escorté
alors complexifie encore la position
c'est son 40e ans s'ils sont tous plus
voir son 41e et
[Musique]
blanc est ce qu'elle est nulle
si je fais prend l'espace par le [ __ ] son
passé
mais ok disons ça voulait reprendre ou
pas chez pas
que je sais faire cavaler sept mois que
la reprise on est en train
d'en apprécier les points qui valent v6
mais grant et 3e
j'ai quand même
très dense est
difficile fort que nous mais ils sont
aussi doit essuyer une pièce ils ont pas
l'ordinateur on risque d'être un
cauchemar
en partir et c'est leur parti de maurice
auprès de dents et long duquel écrire
des choses ans d'amour alors que nous la
d27 position c'est très dur
de calculer
ce savoir des courses de pions mais y en
a partout dans tous les sens à un gros
client avec un 4ème tour donc ça crée
des terres et des menaces à chaque ou
avec toujours cette idée est de priver
la tour de la classe c vide ou un espion
là
c'est donc là c'est lors de la sa
position je pense pour le laisser
réfléchir
on le rappelle
on va peut-être faire juste une dernière
partie qu'on a paru en fait avant
leur bord ouais on va voir rapport vite
vite fait on les a pas vus
à
[ __ ] couleurs opposées
j'avais annoncé dans un rapport en début
de partie
doublé après le roi est un des plus
actifs miniers ce qui a des chances de
gagner ici pour le moment cette finale
d'après toi c'est un petit bonheur de
jouer à ses membres et non je compte que
c'est prévoir
au moins il se ressent
cette
idée de
donner sa paire de fou pour tenter de
rentrer là dedans
mais ce qui le faisait pas ça ne m'était
pas débloqué
hockey
et maintenant moi cette aile et croit le
monde nul
bancaire bâle iii 2016
et on l'a alex qui me dit campus à petit
prix bas s'ils payent cours comme
souvent elle s'est montrée très saignant
et à peut-être réussi à
s'en sortir
quand tu vois la blessure
était resté paradoxe il y beaucoup de
quoi il se passait des choses
aujourd'hui nettement sur tout
l'échiquier c'est un peu la folie mais
déjà deux résultats décisifs plus
humaine marc andrieu
mais cette position qu'elle perd ce
droit doit
mettre la pression ici
hérouard 6 à 5
il a pu échanger des tables jasper cost
est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle quoi qu'il en
soit même si sa position demeure mais
c'est désagréable comment et parler le
plumage très faible
le roi un peu dans sa cage ici
c'est encore une autre faiblesse
principale le contrôler c'est d'avoir
cette casse pour le cavalier l'inflation
mais sinon il n'y a pas grand chose de
bien de ma position
l'accord ne met
en rage aussi ce qui est d'arriérés
c'est de l'argent
il en
allait tourner cette sévère active
il joue vraiment sur le 3g va récupérer
son ok c'est bon d'être
ici
il a résolu ses problèmes
sur sa bécane
j'ai commencé par se seraient accélérées
loi ça continue
jamais tu l'as cannes
à sa guise en train de ranger les ss
et ça ça fait nul ça a dû faire du
mariage viennent de ranger les pièces
moi j'ai pas j'ai pas la caméra bouge
pas d'accord c'est parce que c'est le
coup et c'est genre non de la tête
pourtant
wells croquer concept pas malin devant
wii après pour lui si je pense qu'il est
content de faire nul après ce qui vient
de subir
non mais cela veut dire qu est élu c'est
de au moins dire que j'arrête de vouloir
forcer j'ai merdé temps pire ou tas
d'instruments qamdo d'aqmi qui manque
quand même pas mal d'occasions et c'est
pas la première fois qu'ils ratent des
positions
il ay la rampe a pas beaucoup de
réussite dans ce tournoi fait des
grosses parties il est vraiment hyper
fort mais il n'a pas de réussite il a du
mal à terminer la finition aussi pas que
maintenant un site aussi peut-être un
nom de juin peut il a fait une grosse
année a peut-être besoin de récupérer
ouais ok sauf bon ben on l'a bien fait
le point
on va revenir dans quelques
roses bon là la fin de cette fois on y
reste encore trois partis au pouvoir
quand même en double de raciste et
notamment la victoire de caroil
intimidant mouais c'est imminent on vous
dit alors juste que je pense à un truc
avant de partir à mon parti caruana de
seconde j'avais une dalle entre demander
si ça pouvait pas d'emprunt eu 2
comprend 1 2 3 1 à
tour des huit
wild 3
fait ça et ça et
c'est pardon
pour
l'âme en gestion sera trop loin de
nous se dit encore en calculant prêt à
prendre
si on échangeait tour de place cette
femme
est active on a bien vu les stats n'a à
mon goût beauf
est
il intéressant
bon au niveau du groupe y est à tout de
suite
[Musique]
à
et
[Musique]
oh
come back se trouve avec donc la partie
de karwan à notre grande et lui aussi
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il ya eu d'un
point aux deux qui est chargé d'âme à ce
que tu avais suggéré
ouais même à 40 miles heure juste avant
qu'on parte on pose mon avis aux
accessoires espoir est grande et lui
sont des renards et s'ils étaient
tellement a par le passé qu'ils à
aller jusqu'au bout il abandonne pas
facilement dans des positions de couture
par caruana ici et réfléchissent
comme la dame on peux vous l'annoncer
et oui avoir un groupe d'artistes enfin
d'autres
s'aperçurent le jambon si j'avais des
jours nous rejoignent
hf va essayer le jeu en vie lol
je sais que
rim je prends courage il a joué par le
passé
league of legends
j'ai pas mal d'années déjà battant je
vais pas jouer avec des formateurs parce
que la communauté hyper toxiques donc ça
c'est pas agréable c'est dur de
dépassement brouille avec frêche par
petites touches c'est vraiment la
poussette communautaire d'arnaud
toxicité à laquelle j'ai jamais été
confronté
sinon le jeu était sympa
je
monte un diamant
correct
et j'ai laissé ça derrière moi et pour
en revenir aux échecs ou qu on va voir
je vois sur scène là entre justin comme
disait donc en fait ça fait dame va pas
se passer comme ça
que
j'ai écrit que les paroles
sont d'un mode affichage et la part
entre la dame karbala sais pas ce qui
s'est passé
cette maj orange paho estiment que j'ai
fait
notre amie files
sur la google i/o grosse pouf il avait
vu la défense de grands débuts ce même
si elles marchent pas
la partie quelques
temps 17 3 e 2 et 30 et on rachète un
hyper facile à gagner ça va être comme
ça je pense que là d'ailleurs je t'aime
je te vois trois prochains coups